[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
USA's best at the American Cup in St
Louis it was game over for two players
with two more down to their last lives
Lavon aronian won his first round
rematch and will face a wounded Wesley
so for the right to battle bracket
Champion Hikaru Nakamura Nazi fakitsi
decimated her opponent advancing to a
clash with a freshly defeated Alice Lee
for a shot at taking down women's
bracket champ Irena Crush it's the
ultimate battle of the beaten with the
final boss in sight day seven of can't
miss chess coming up next
[Music]
foreign
of the 2023 American Cup held at the St
Louis chess club well today we are in
front of the Saint Louis chess club and
as you can see behind me there's been
some renovation going on well I cannot
wait to see what the next move is going
to be for the Saint Louis chess club and
the next move is going to be for our
players as well let's go to studio and
start the action with Jovi and Yasir
we welcome you to St Louis Missouri the
capital of Chess in America this is day
seven of the 2023 American Cup and the
Saint Louis chess club
[Music]
hello and a really warm welcome from the
St Louis chess club I'm International
master ivankajowska and it's been a
great pleasure to be calling all the
thrilling action alongside the one and
only Grandmaster yes to Sarah Juan Jovi
it's been wonderful calling the action
with you and Christian I mean lots of
Thrills and Spills and lots more in
store
number one seeds are number one seeds
for a reason they win a lot Hikaru and
Arena took care of business in the
Champions bracket and they're waiting
for the winners of the elimination
bracket Jovi do the honors and tell us
where we stand let's look into it and
here we see the Champions bracket is
completed and might have gone to tie
breaks but it was Hikaru Nakamura that
was triumphant over Wesley so Wesley now
dropping down to the elimination bracket
right and when it comes to the
elimination bracket here is what's going
to be happening Wesley is going to be
facing against none of other than Levon
aronian these two met in 2022 and I was
I love honoronium that was triumphant
we'll see what happens today it will be
decided and in the women's champion and
in the women's bracket wow what a
performance between the two top seeds
Arena crash and Alice Lee but it was
Arena that reigned triumphant and she is
now waiting for the Victor in that comes
gonna come up from the elimination
bracket because Alice Lee has dropped
down and she will be facing off against
the player he was really being on red
hot form Nazi pikitsa and well we'll see
what happens today it will be decided in
the elimination bracket final as we see
Naji at the board really getting into
the Zone
um but do you remind our viewers of the
format for the tournament yes because
these players
they well we're just going to focus on
the elimination bracket today because
that's all that's happening and the
players will play a two-game rapid 25
minutes plus 10 second increment and
remember no draw offers allowed never a
bad in Saint Louis and the schedule and
today schedule and today's schedule
there is a rest day for those Champions
and from the champion bracket they're
not playing instead the focus will go on
the elimination bracket with the two
players will play there's two rapid
games and if the match is tied it's
going to go down to tie breaks and
playoffs and possibly even all the way
to an Armageddon we'll find out
absolutely it looks like a good show in
store and good to have you with us in
studio Christian uh drill down and tell
us about the elimination bracket and how
the players got there good to see you
guys great to be back in the studio and
we have an exciting day ahead of
ourselves yesterday we've seen those
incredible matches in the Champions
bracket the one between Hikaru Nakamura
and Wesley so that went all the way to
the blitz section and that game between
Irina crush and Alice Lee Arena was half
a second away from elimination while she
would have moved on to the elimination
bracket if she wouldn't have slapped the
clock in time but she did she drew that
game and then won to win at the match in
the playoffs and that allowed her to be
in the grand finals and also get that
nice five thousand dollar bonus because
of the Champions bracket but let's take
a look at how the players from the
elimination bracket got to where they
are today we're going to start off with
Alice Lee the youngest participant in
this event feeder Master at least she
won in dominant fashion against atusa
percussion tuo in her first match after
that against Naji pakiza who she will be
meeting in today's match she won that
one with the black pieces is very very
important event and let's take a look at
Naji and her results so far one her
initial match against the struggling
anastasi one and a half to a half after
that lost against Alice Lee a dominant
performance against tatev abrahamian and
yesterday what a match she played
against
today she will be facing a player that
defeated her earlier in the competition
that is feed Master Alice Lee and let's
go on to the Champions bracket the
elimination bracket that is in the open
section and of course one of the
participants is Wesley so who was
defeated Yesterday by the rating
favorite Hikaru Nakamura in his first
match he one in the playoffs two and a
half against Sam Shanklin after that
defeated the reigning Champion that is
Fabiano caruana in also in the playoffs
two and a half to one and a half and
yesterday what a match that was against
the current Nakamura and I have to say
he was out playing Hikaru in those rapid
matches unfortunately for him he was
unable to take the full points home
whenever he had those decisive
advantages and fell under the sharp
sword of Hikaru nakamurai and look at
him he looks relaxed he looks ready to
have some fun and punch his ticket to
the Grand finals once again against
Ricardo Nakamura but today he has such a
difficult match ahead of himself because
he's facing this man Grand Master Levon
aronian who started off with a loss this
competition well he didn't really like
playing classical chess and after that
he started playing rapid and Bliss chess
and he was winning all the way hey to
yesterday's match against Lanier toku
revenge in the playoffs one and a half
to a half and right now he is in the
elimination bracket finals against
Wesley so and
look at him entering the hole he really
likes that jacket doesn't he he's he's
been wearing it since he received it at
the beginning of the show and I have to
say it's such a beautiful jacket but
guys if you are feeling like you're
having some Deja Vu from last year well
let's take a look at what happened last
year and we're going to start off with
the lady section it was this matchup in
the grand finals between Grand Master
Irina crush and Alice Lee Crush
defeatedly in the Champions semi-final
Lee went on to win the elimination
bracket she has the chance to do so
today but Crush defeated Alice Lee for
the championship and in the open section
well we had a similar story but one
Hikaru Nakamura did not play last year
aronia won the elimination bracket
winning three matches but karuana did
not lose a single match he stayed in the
Champions bracket and won the first
match of the grand finals to take home
the title guys we have an exciting day
ahead of ourselves of rapid and
potentially Bliss Jazz thank you
Christian indeed we do and as we watch
these Players Get Ready for Action
they've been fighting really hard and
what have they been fighting for Jovi a
lot of money a lot of money I mean take
a look at this in the open section the
first prize is fifty thousand dollars
second place thirty five thousand twenty
five thousand dollars but hikara has
already netted himself ten thousand
dollars because he won the champion
brackets and gets a bonus very nice and
in the uh ladies section in the women's
section you see first prize 25
000 second 18 000 and 10 000 and of
course Arena has also picked up a bonus
for winning the champion bracket five
thousand
and as we get ready for these
illumination uh games I must say from
the start of the tournament Alice Lee
was incredible she really made such a
powerful impression but after her slip
up yesterday and the fact that Naji has
been playing
really excellent chess I kind of feel
that's a call a match just as I feel
that this too is uh well pick them yeah
who do you like now 93 inviting Bishop
B4 that's the rogozi that's what Levon
usually plays and anyways it is like his
bread and butter he always goes Bishop
B4 right and I'm probably now having
said always always he's gonna go Bishop
E7 the commentators cursed he seems if
he hasn't played it yet maybe he's going
to shy away from that yes and the coat
comes off I mean we know that in this
rapid playoffs your mechanics have to be
top-notch yeah exactly as uh we do oh no
that's my move 98 to D7 okay that's
trying to avoid the bishop F4 lines you
can still play before yeah but
it's not so effective I feel when uh
when the night is already on D7 so yes
Bishop to F4 you take on C4 in general
and you have the option after the move
E3 to defend that pawn on C4 with the
Knight coming to B6 that's why the
Knight landing on D7 early on is so
important which is E3 and in the Ladies
by the way we have a very interesting uh
development going on here as Naji again
has essayed uh early uh
fianchetta King side fee and Shadow C5
and a near invitation to going into a
benoni and Alice has just played a
peculiar looking move Bishop E2 uh
you look at that you kind of go well why
don't you want to play Knight C3 she
might have been worried about Bishop
takes C3 Knight F3 she might have been
worried about a pin so she played Bishop
E2 and waiting for her opponent By Night
of sex Jovi yeah I was just gonna say
you know this is kind of like delayed
benoni type position because you know
yes you can go E6 but often you see it
they can they don't do it immediately
they can do it later on in the the day
they also go for these like Nike six
Nike seven plans and I wanted to mention
one thing about najib which I've noticed
she's been like ducking and Diving when
it comes to her opening repertoire she's
really picked out what she thinks is
gonna inconvenience or unsettle to her
opponents the most and it's been working
a treat and I've really been impressed
by her play the one thing I have to say
about this particular move order from
Naji with the move E7 E6 is it does give
her her an option that you don't
normally ever get
in a benoni normally the Knight is on F6
and then you play I don't know A6 B5
Knight H5 what have you in this
particular position you do have the
unusual opportunity of playing in 97
castles and a quick F5 normally the
Knight is always standing on F6 in this
particular moment after E6 one other
thought I had when you play the move
Bishop E2 in this particular position
uh playing a Benco Gambit where
oftentimes white does want to recapture
with the bishop
there's a reason why you might be in
inclined to go in that direction that
did not happen E7 E6 Knight C3 on the
board expecting E6 takes D5 yep okay I'm
expecting that shall we go back to see
what uh Lavon did after Knight B8 D7
again uh
doubtlessly a big surprise for Wesley uh
Wesley certainly expecting Bishop B4 and
over gozen after Knight B8 D7 no Bishop
F4 no Bishop G5 let's just play E2 E3 a
quiet line Bishop to E7
b2b3 and we've caught up to the play
players normally speaking castles Bishop
B2 C7 C5 and or B7 B6 are the two most
popular ways of meeting this quiet setup
of e3 and B3 yeah I must admit that I
did try my hand with these positions
with the white pieces and I found that
actually lots of people didn't
understand how to play the position as
black and I got quite promising
positions against even top Grandma well
not top Grandmaster but Grandmaster
Grand Masters okay and um but I but I
have to say I once played Lawrence Trent
and he crushed me in this and then I
thought oh no and when you get burnt
you're like no I'm not touching that one
again and what was the fire that uh he
just put you well I think he went for
the B6 the choir to B6 systems and
somehow or other I think yeah B6 Bishop
B7 and went for this kind of plan and I
I did all the happy moves as wide you
know you put your missions
there came a stage when there was no
happy move any longer and I couldn't
think of how to extend any further and I
thought okay this is quite subtle let's
switch to the London system the battle
right now goes uh between black wanting
to play the move C5 after you finish
your development like this and white
wanting to be first to play E4 and
striking the center so you're thinking
of ideas of Queen to E2 followed by E4
things of that nature right
or even captures and
followed by E4
oftentimes when I'm Wide in these
positions I like a a little
clarification I like playing this move
in particular I want
my opponent to declare their intentions
for example Knight takes D5 Knight takes
D5 Bishop takes D5 I may be so inclined
is to play Queen E2 Rook D1 and Rook C1
playing for E4 at the moment Black's
Queen
doesn't have the convenient Square E7
and in case you take with the pawn which
is also a very popular recapture nothing
wrong with it this bishop on B2 can now
get opened after I move my knight I
bring I shift my knight to the G3 square
and I prep D4 take C5 I kind of like
White's position that was not what
um
Wesley did Wesley played no sorry
there's no uh there's no C5 it was H7 no
Castle no no Castle he didn't start with
Castle he delayed castle and played the
move Queen to C2 now this is a break
it's an increasing line and by the way I
was looking through the database
the best players playing this variation
with white pieces well there's three
games with the name Wesley saw so Wesley
has played this position with the white
pieces some could say that he's an
expert right in this line and what
surprises me is that Levon actually is
thinking right now because if he did
indeed prepare this move knight bd7 from
home and wanted to have it as a surprise
he should have watched these games by
Wesley but this uh in in levon's defense
if he hasn't studied this I mean Wesley
Festival plays anything and everything
yes and also I mean Wesley is mainly
like a bishop F4 player I'm Sorry by
Bishop F4 I mean he develops his Bishop
to F4 when confronted with Knight bd7 or
in the so I think and also his main
lines usually started with Knight C3 at
move three and a lot of names though yes
so this probably was an early Surprise
by Wesley with Knight F3 followed by
Knight to C3 and then Levon tried to
surprise Wesley back with Knight bd7 but
Wesley seems to know what he's doing
well well just to clarify uh after the
move Queen C2 in fact Lavon very quickly
played the move h7h6
if you do go C5 instead of H6
I take on D5 and now you don't have the
very natural recapture with the Knight
you're right you have to take with the
pawn and then we get them into this type
of positions with potentially the
hanging pawns after d takes C5 B takes
C5 exactly perhaps this is something
that
Levant didn't want to see just one
simple fact that you know it is a
structural weakness sometimes and Wesley
loves to play against this type of
hanging pawns and I think he was not
necessarily afraid but he wanted to shy
away from it that's what he started with
H6 now C5 is a pretty serious threat
yeah and I was just looking at a rather
consequent line let's say I capture
Knight takes Knight takes Bishop takes
in this case I'm rather trying seeking
to justify the move H7
h64 and Bishop db4 so I am encouraging
you to
um stop me from castling yeah uh I don't
feel that the King on E2 is going to
stay in the center too long my intention
is quickly to play King F1 after I get
my Rook out so
by the way none of this was played he
played Rook to D1 okay no taking on D5
no taking on D5 no E4 just Rook to D1
getting ready to meet that move C5 which
by the way instantaneously came on
yeah I was gonna ask that question you
know what is White gonna do after C5 I
mean my idea is to carry on as normal
that's probably the best what's normal
is that I always try to simplify in the
center
yeah uh this natural looking move in
this specific position Rook D1 is not in
the database it is not no no
castles all more common well
in fact another way Rook D1 is news
after age six in fact in my database and
I know our producer has a much better
database than us in my database I don't
have any games wow after H6 and Rook to
D1 by the way is the computer's Choice
yeah so it doesn't seem like yeah
perhaps Wesley is still within his
opening preparation one of the things I
was going to say about please move H6 I
mean it doesn't radically change the
nature of the position I mean it just
is it developing luxurious move right
and the plans are still going to be the
same for both sides clear so this is
this OCD yeah if you take with the
Knight I will take back on D5 and Knight
takes D5 Bishop takes D5 take back on C5
and you'll take now on cc5 yes but
Knight takes
this is where Bishop H7 check I see a
little bit
awkward he's going for it look Wesley
still knows what he's doing
and now e4n this is unpleasant this is
in fact let's see a little bit uh I mean
the taking on C5 Knight takes C5 is
clearly the most desirable recapture I
may have to
yes yes and if you do take uh with the
bishop it's still not very pleasant
after the move E4 once again the Knight
on D7 is kind of stuck you have to
retreat to C6 because otherwise Bishop
to B5 is coming and you're almost lost
you have to Define it with Bishop C8
that's very ugly right right uh you have
to go back to C6 but the problem is look
at these two Bishops I can start
attacking it with a move A3 try to kick
them back you have to defend with A5 by
Castle I still have the idea of before
I'm pushing you back with every single
one of my moves I'm just not giving you
any room to breathe and it does seem
like the engines are recommending this
as much better for white already and
most likely Wesley knows this what sorry
isn't that that surprises me it's low
end because you know I always judge this
type of position by whether the Queen
the black queen sorry can find a safe
home and she can put herself on E7 it
seems to be very uh very concrete
careful
there is a B4 oh wow I thought you were
going to say queen to C7
there was a tactical
apologies you're absolutely right Bishop
A4
yeah about one second which pay for
Queen C3 that attacks Checkmate okay
you've got your tricks I've got my
tricks I guess yes or Christian has his
tricks Queen to see three and don't
don't be thinking about The Rook you
have to take a time out and then I get
your Bishop I get the two Bishops okay
that's not part of it no I just wanted
Bishop A4 but Queen C7 is there a
refutation to this move
suppose that you just can you you could
play the move Knight D4 and you're
you're probably enjoying yourself yeah
Queen C7 I go B4 B4 still
oh wait Queen C7 after eight okay A5 and
castle no this is a bit different this
is a bit different because this one
there's no
what if I still continue with Queen to
C3 and then before
okay that makes a lot a lot of sense uh
right here Queen to C3 Checkmate threat
I wanted to play Knight F6 but now be
foreign right
and you're just not getting in time
right uh early problems and well that
leaves I was going to ask the question
yeah about the third question the
unhappiest option of all is splitting my
pawns with B6 take C5 he's played Bishop
takes C5 has Lavon Lavon said I don't
like the split pawns but this move E3 E4
that's a really
nice
pressure suddenly for white this Rook on
D1 is really
turning the tables right
do I have Rook C8 no no wait Rook C8 at
one point
right now because you got Bishop before
check I do queen C3 again
let me show Christian what he missed we
call this a discovered okay check
get out of here get out of here
you can tell that you weren't all older
brother yes yes yes goodness but my
brother and I we love the wrestling and
uh he being the younger brother all of
the wrestling holds that the I I
practiced on my little brother you know
you know the Boston crab you know he's
full full uh uh holds uh E4 Rook C8 did
we refute Rook ca Castle
okay Castle can't I
didn't I dodge uh but where do you put
the bishop
um well no you can buy Bishops C6 Bishop
is seven but why well I I wanna I Wanna
Stop these this queen C3 kind of
businesses uh Bishop E7 if you've put
your queen back on B1 I put my Bishop I
don't know the Bishop back to C6 and now
you still have Knight D4 I'm not out of
the woods I'm not saying I have Bishop
A6 also you have Bishop A6 also yeah
where do you put the Rook
uh if I go Rook C7 now you've I have
ideas on Bishop E5 yes you do also do
you have like ideas of Knight E5 as well
no Bishop B5 is good
before a rook and a and a bishop but
yeah uh Rook C8 is not uh a Panacea and
by the way Castles by Wesley he didn't
want he wasn't waiting for Rook C8 after
Bishop takes C5 he did not play the move
E4 which we felt was kind of good for
him actually castles on the board
inviting Bishop takes F3 you know I
might be so inclined is to take that
well to I I mean it's just that
I was getting
into positions I really did not like is
black I mean I may not be liking this
one either
but okay I at least I kind of completed
my development you you could go King H1
and Rook G1 and I do think you're having
the fun don't don't get me wrong I I I I
I prefer White's position but I'm just
saying that in this position right here
right now
I'm looking at E4 and I don't like the
consequences of what is happening and uh
well we see Lavon by the way Queen E7
very quickly yeah he just puts his Queen
on E7 and well there's a difference now
like in the past we were putting the
bishop on C6 because we were now we can
put the bishop on B7 after Bishop B5
there's no pin and we're we're we're
home free we're driving wait wait wait
wait yes there's still ideas please of
playing
B4 with the queen
okay yeah with the queen jumping down to
C7 gotcha
I I I I
appreciate yes uh there's some pins
someone someone did this to me so yeah
no it's okay I'm gonna do it to you of
course uh I'm game uh Queen drops down
to C7 and if I make a a defensive move
like Rook to B8 yeah yeah then
presumably yeah this is my idea but my
Queen's protected Jovi I can just
it's it's not yeah actually now that I
think about it yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
visually yeah Queen C7 looks like it
might win material so you think about
the move B4 right right yeah
so we're looking for a refutation uh
helpers out Christian no Queenie seven
um it seems to be quite decent for black
right now in fact okay yes yes yes
Castle was not the best movie in the
position E4 would have given Wesley the
advantage and I'm sure he has it in his
files but he just simply didn't remember
the best move he played Castle which is
the most natural right in the position
by far yeah but unfortunately after a
queen to E7 it seems like black finally
manages to assemble its defense uh in
the center and on the king side
accurately and this is exactly what
Levon just did for this move Queen to E7
he's very very close to solving all his
opening problems right now
yeah so you're saying that the natural
castles was actually a serious imp
ressive decision yes yes that as a
result uh the advantage kind of
dissipated Slipped Away
okay it did it truly did yeah and uh
okay whilst the players have still got
lots of things to fight for in this
position shall we go over to let's do it
the game between Alice Lee and Naji
because we left it here yep and if you
refresh you're gonna be in for a treat I
have to say because that happened and
first of all you know Naji really is
choosing the most combative openings you
know because here she could have taken
on D5 you know she could have played
into something mainstream instead she's
like Bishop takes Knight yeah this is a
an idea of Roman jinji hash Valley the
jinji Indian as we used to call it but
he did not play it with the move E7 E6
he captured and played it with the move
F7 F5 after takes takes E5 okay trying
to shut down the position saying you've
got the two Bishops but as so long as I
can keep the position closed the Bishops
aren't really going to feel there at
their full strength by the way Bishop D3
so that's the tempo being given back if
you will Knight D7
92 okay in this case we can see that
uh Alice is keeping F2 F4 in reserve she
she wants to be able to open up the
position for her two Bishops Queen E7 H3
now this is a Rio page out of the jinji
Indian Playbook the King on C7 is
actually really the best Square you can
imagine that white is going to Castle if
you put your King on the king side with
castles F2 F4 in the dark Square Bishop
you may Rue the day that you tried the
fee and Shadow but the King on C7 on the
other hand no Bishop A5 checks the king
will find safety doesn't it
pretty much solves her opening problems
maybe even is better right now
Knight F6 just a simple Knight F6 Knight
F6 and
the bishop will have to retreat and
tanks I get the Knight to E5 next well
well well well well well
um
okay so Knight f495
and I do have Knight H5 but I'm a little
bit concerned 195 I think I'm just going
to go Ro Cafe I'm going to give you the
exchange and ask you okay you got my
exchange but you have some problems with
the dark swears and if I manage to get
F4 once you Castle short most likely
then you're going to be indeed I don't
have to not immediately yeah I I don't
have to resolve this tension right away
okay can I take a pawn yes
good question but I don't know I feel
like that pawn wasn't that worth that
much
the the part on C4 is no greater yes H5
right that takes H5 that takes yeah oh
sorry same idea it was a bit of a yeah
yeah a a bit of a blow
I'm fortunate I get it okay you're
targeting my night I go back
okay but it's not that easy for you to
resolve uh the tension here like
I I understand you I agree You're Gonna
Go Bishop here Bishop here and then I
will take the exchange so maybe I can
prep something like F3
so for example Bishop to D7 F3 no no no
no no you can't
sure night takes time right ah Knight G3
but you can go you can grab the exchange
first a nice spot nice spot no it takes
so it takes now yeah but now I have
Queen G7 all the time right not yet
because then you take take only four and
that looks good for you correct um even
though okay let's go into that variation
for a second
I'm kind of curious whether I have any
sort of compensation this is the svensar
gligerich school of Chess where you
sacrifice uh a pawn in the king's Indian
you know I really like this F3 coming
Bishop takes H3 after that I don't know
it feels good there's some compensation
there I I do agree uh but in this but
she's uh yes no no no no she has not
played Knight F6 yeah she plays Knight
df6 Knight D F6 but it doesn't feel good
that doesn't feel right
I like that night on E5 in all of those
uh variations
I can only imagine that she was afraid
that for example now she was she's
afraid of this pin and she wants to keep
H6 and G5 yeah in reserve to break
position 93 now Knight G3
so after age six night takes Bishop
right yes you know what I'm going to be
even more aggressive aggressive
I'm going to go G4
G4 why not well as we say in the opening
you have three
obligations to control the center to
develop your pieces to good squares
and to find safety for your king when
you when you as white
when you've got your let's say broken
Queen site structure that's okay Knight
G3 now you're going to have to put your
king where you're telling me over there
telling me all these beautiful stories
yeah it's gonna recapture no no no no
yes yes for sure Bishop E3 I'm not
giving you that Bishop not in a million
years okay
let's go Castle long
whoa let's have some fun
okay so now I know your address and I
don't think your address is a very good
address it doesn't look like it's a
comfy home huh okay uh be careful
be careful I have E4 is a little bit
tender huh maybe something else let's
see if you spot it H5 it is very early
in the morning it's true true
on C5
oh yes I haven't spotted that one
actually no I was thinking of Queen E8
for a different reason to get out of the
the your spine races your spices but it
wasn't it wasn't intended as a way of
sidestepping your thread more like how
do I get my knight to uh on G8 into the
game the more I'm looking at this I'm
not happy I do believe that uh whites
for Choice Christian uh the Knight on G8
and the Knight on F6 are stepping in
each other's uh toes and I like this
h3g4
because I I can't resolve my king side
Queen E3 Queen E3
I sort of like this idea so was it
possible she was afraid of G4 E3 I think
so yeah yeah 43 and maybe just sacrifice
the pawn and yeah
Queen E3 was her choice I like this move
you do okay
H6 is the yes but now I go by 40
and you still don't have time to go G5
yet why not because of Queen takes C5 ah
but yes that's nice Queen takes C5 well
before he's coming let's see if and now
[Music]
be careful between take C5 don't miss
that and if you go B6 by the way now I'm
starting to have some squares yeah C6
Bishop A4 Bishop C6 ideas right it's
going to be challenged by the bishop on
F5 coming back to D7 but still it's it's
a square Because by the way this is a
nice Tempo I mean white doesn't lose
anything if you play B6 and I play G4
it's like I've included the move Queen
E3 sorry Jerry yeah I was gonna say um
the only way that I conceded
there's a lot of dancing around with
them but isn't there a G4 issue
I was hoping for G5 G5 I take and then I
take with the Knight on F4 and my knight
comes to easy
okay this is
okay 97 okay you like uh what actually
Christian said yeah yeah I do too
I'm not even gonna go there yeah right
Zona back back yeah uh in fact right now
according to the engine has a decisive
Advantage I don't doubt it because Queen
takes C5 is a huge Tempo G4 and this
this Pawn could just be dropping off and
she has to defend it right she has to go
B6
and now I can play Simple chess I can
just go Castle apparently
short Castle yeah well they're your king
what whoa no Queen C5 and Alice she must
not have to be asked why she missed it
wow this is game over you don't even
have King D7 because of Bishop A4
this is completely game over Bishop A4
check ouch and if you have to go back I
think thank you so much she can't resign
at this point she just lost her Center
yep that's it that's resignation she
missed it wow and it's an easy move to
miss because
you kind of complacent you think your
structure D6 E5 is just so strong that
nothing is attacking it Queen C5 cold
shower
ouch
yeah but I think already something had
gone wrong right here uh
with this this move uh night
um D7 F6 uh that after that moved Bishop
to C2 white was really uh in the
driver's seat
the other move uh Bishop G5 Knight
that's a lot more unclear because the
Knight would end up on the E5 Square the
current position well
sadly for naji's fans it's game over
here
d8 Bishop takes Bishop after this one
Nazi is going to be in a Mastery
situation
Bishop takes D6 well what's really
tragic is you just played the move G6 G5
saying to the bishop you must move
and white says okay if you insist I'm
gonna play Bishop takes D6 it was like
no that was not what I had in mind when
I played the move G5
so the bishop can come back
Queen will come back
terrible things are going to be maybe I
can try to be even more aggressive try
to get the night
I was thinking Knight to D4
Knight to D4 looks well yeah looks
overwhelming that's for sure the problem
is you also once again the Knight on G8
is not going anywhere true you cannot go
to E7 because I exchange and the bishop
0.5 is hanging exactly
she goes before 94. is there any Rook
c8s you know I'm just really yeah yeah
it is a gravel right yeah Queen goes to
B4 ideas of Bishop A4 you possibility of
Queen A5 check but uh yeah well two
pawns up and I've got the attack okay
and uh okay so well things are looking
great for creating a 13 year old Alice
Lee is what I want to say yes uh what is
happening in the the game between Wesley
and
it just happened a little bit of a quite
calm game Queen and then I'm sorry
something happened Let me refresh my
board I apologize
something did happen yeah um okay so
when we left it we saw the move Queen E7
an idea we we considered in a different
uh setup was check and Bishop E4
and
A5 wow
A5 I find that kind of remarkable he
must have been afraid of B4 and Rook
takes B7 Rook takes D7 ideas A5 Queen F4
um well this one I think we can all spot
yeah I mean uh Queen takes H6 check uh
taking advantage of the fact that the
pawn on G7 is pinned King H7
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa G4
well guess who woke up in a combatitude
today I mean G4 what do you say about
them apples Christian I love it you love
your life is coming or how do you defend
against it F6
maybe F6 maybe F6 is not such a bad move
whatever
it says never play F6 but yeah you like
exposing your king like that no not
really but you know
irresistible to go forward
okay so okay so personally huge threat
right well personally I hate the move
okay so let me be frank so let's say uh
I I even encourage you go for it G5 okay
F6
I mean I think you're exposing your king
more than you're getting to my king and
then take H6
just go for it
G5
oh my
somebody's having some fun here I'm not
sure who who's doing the yeah let me
play E5 I apologize let me play E5 what
I want to do is I want to close down
your Bishop which I've successfully done
and if you have to play Queenie for
check I will in that case play the move
G6
my Rook on A7 was just a move to Parry
any threats of Queen F5 check attacking
my knight
so in other words I was just challenging
the idea so we go back just a second so
G5 F6
this is the current situation and I'm
suggesting Rook A7 is a pass move
uh G5 yeah
so I I wanted to ask really how big a
threat is G5
what happens if I go
Pawn to um so what if I just take
yes always but if you take the Age part
yeah that's that's what we were
discussing just now and then if E5 and I
was trying to close down this bishop yes
I was being very sneaky you know thank
you very much
all compliments great for what we
received
I think called a lot worse than sneaky I
gotta tell you and that's our
resignation I really do have a result
let's just see what the final position
looked like I mean it was a it was an
accident uh in the center of the board
here for Naji as we left it Bishop takes
D6 oh dear
Queen D7 Knight D4 Rook CA Queen B4
ideas of Bishop A4 suddenly are in the
position and after 98 Bishop E5 Rook A7
G4 yeah
no no no no no this was not this was
disaster I mean sometimes it's good just
to play a really really really horrible
game because then it's not on your mind
anymore you don't you don't kick
yourself you lose a game that's really
close a Tempo here or a Tempo there
makes all the difference no
that can haunt you this game doesn't
that was just the best this is a bad bad
day at the office and then you can
continue and like you said this kind of
there's some
Liberation actually attention that
you're feeling because you know now
you're free exactly the next game you
know you know exactly what you have to
do you know right it's ride or die time
exactly
and here is the big moment of the
blunder uh she has just played the move
Queen E3 did Alice uh setting up this
nasty Queen take C5 check she was only
looking on one side of the board exactly
and Alice boy and look at the Hatchery
you see the hat trick immediately after
she sees Alice reaching for that pawn
shop their senses right oh oh oh oh
Queen takes C5 we've all been there done
that uh let's jump to the elimination
bracket for
um
yeah the open section as we've got this
game between Wesley and Lavon and and
Lavon has played this move G4 and uh I
just asked is G5 a threat so I made this
move Rook A7 is should he play H4 what
should he do he said no he says I'm
going to go G5
went down your route
accelerated version no he did not have
yeah Knight F6 Knight F6 there was a
difference because what what I really
wanted to do was blunt this bishop yeah
and I did want to play F6 and E5 to do
that I didn't want to see the queen
landing on C7 that was where Rook A7
also came from uh Lavon
was much more aggressive he just said
you play G4 dude you want to play G5 and
aren't you getting it okay I was gonna
ask this like the caveman wow it says
you know take a keyboard approach
exactly put the King on G8 and OSU mate
I go for mates and I'm thinking queen
queen
yeah Bishop takes night in the air
exactly and you
right exactly this looks gross uh
does he want to run probably he wants to
make room for his King in case a bishop
takes everything please yeah and if you
carry on you continue with
how do we do club the club approach I'm
going to club right
yeah four E4 yeah okay that I I I
understand the caveman approach now I
mean I get it you're gonna hit me with
E4 E5 and I'm gonna be hurting yeah no
E5 stop that stop hurting me
actually now that I think about it can I
hurt you
takes that's not part of the deal yeah
yeah right
I was thinking you might go because
there there could be a check on the back
rank that oh hang on no no Rick takes
work Rick takes you're going to be so
proud of me yesterday Queen H.A check
well no but E6 is hanging I like what
you this actually happened in the world
championship match between Alexander
alekine and
um uh Professor Max irva and both
players have missed this queen h8
combination you're right you are losing
E4 because I forgot about F2 I thought
yeah well but I I mean you you found a
combination that two world champions
didn't
so okay to take about early morning
that's all you get that's it it's all
downhill from here exactly been more fun
for you wild okay uh what's happening
Christian what does it what say the
engine is it's not that easy it's not
that easy truly it's not that easy yeah
Queen to H4 rook fd8 and it seems like I
have to do something along the lines of
Bishop to E5 and by the way Bishop to E5
is the only move that maintains the
advantage
probably for the reason that we have
kind of understood black wants to play
E5 and close uh close shop for the
bishop B2 so let's get the bishop to E5
and stabilize the position as it is and
our Rook to D5 still working against the
bishop only five Rook takes D5 I would
assume e takes D5 you cannot move with a
knight you get track made it Knight
takes D5 yeah yeah good luck good luck
escaping with the queen on E7 that's
game over so
this is the critical variation right now
if it doesn't do that and black manages
to stabilize the position well the pawn
structure for black is better you are a
bit overextended with your pieces on the
on the king side so it's not that easy
right you need to be very careful if I
manage to exchange uh both Rooks on the
D file then black could even be better
at some point only six minutes right now
remaining for Wesley so against 10
minutes
and I have to say levon's moves are easy
you're just defending against Checkmate
King H1 he's going for Rook to G1 yes he
is I mean the caveman approach of hey
I've got the half open G file
um
it's a decent movie yeah first blush I
kind of like that move actually yeah
it's a good move Rook to d8 okay that
preps the king walk takes the age takes
d8 Rook takes d8 and then Rook to G1 is
what uh Wesley has in mind
now
the king
is potentially not happy on this light
Square diagonal I mean there is a queen
B7
and maybe this queen king to H1 was was
a really good move was a good move it
seems like it was a really good move by
Wesley yes why uh so we're expecting
Rook takes do you do yeah Queen B7 or
heavy for it right
sorry just a second I I just want to see
that Queen B7 check or wait give me just
one second sorry it's a knight F3 well
no I mean it's it's white to move here
right right um
after he just wants to go Knight F3 so
after E4 you want to go Bishop D4 right
is that your move after E4 my attention
was Bishop to D4 he shot the D4 okay but
uh what about F3
f
3 first yeah okay I will I will back off
as they say okay and queen queen moves
to H Falls if I get it now yeah and then
I was my intention whether you like it
or not was to
Munch his spawn okay and I was gonna get
on my walking shoes and hide but hang on
can you yeah
okay
you you do have a way maybe of snaring
my queen I'm not 100 sure about this
takes takes check and maybe Rook takes
G7
how I am
okay so there's tactics here and how how
does the engine feel about this move
King H1 uh Christian very good very good
yes yes the engine wasn't even spotting
that moving to H1 uh previously and
after he played it the engine is now
jumping and giving an almost decisive
Advantage wow
I would not have guessed that Jovi would
you I mean I I like the initiative don't
get me wrong I think it's a nice attack
I had no idea it was deadly deadly I
just thought that uh so it is actually
Knight to F3 in the line that we
discussed a queen B7 check Knight to F
Knight F3 and this is just Brute Force
right now because you go 98 yeah and now
I take on G7 with the bishop with the
bishop ah and queen F6 I was thinking
that I would always have Bishop f8 but I
mean everything comes with Tempo you
take on G7 yeah isn't that nice I didn't
see it either I thought I was going to
take a nicely done and then this end
game is just very unpleasant I think
we King for black exactly
wow wow incredible stuff
that extra Pond
very meaningful very meaningful six
minutes right now for both players
remaining difficult position for levonne
and he's thinking what we capture with
on DNA you know when I missed a
Christian when you came on broadcast one
of the things that you've been telling
us is how these players uh match up head
to head in classical and Rapids and you
didn't give me that content that I love
that uh who who's better in Rapid chess
between these things with the producer
yeah sir come on you know better than
that take it out with the producer lay
me for everything
where's my agent man
I did I have okay the last in 2022 yeah
2023 two drawers in tata steel and WR
Masters okay and then you know in 2022
the two have been trading blows okay so
I know that Wesley lost in 23 moves
somewhere in one of the grand Chester
really 23 moves yeah wow that's a that's
a big one and then but there's two kind
of trade blows all the time
boy I
before you said that I I mean Wesley
losing a miniature you know he hadn't
been nine years old at the time he lost
a miniature he doesn't do that anymore
uh the queen B7 check is on the board
and it's this Knight F3 move and what
what are you going to do and I really
have to tell you I mean I was just so
impressed with the way Wesley played
yesterday he the rapid portion against
Hikaru especially I'll played him with
the white pieces then he beat him on
Demand with the black pieces he could
have easily won that match to roll oh
yeah the rapid portion oh yes after that
in the blitz it was a completely
different story Hikaru really started to
warm up the engines but yes in in the
rapid portion Wesley's is really really
good uh sorry to interrupt but Lavon has
been thinking so long for good reason
that he he really is seriously
considering Queen takes d8 shall we look
at that yeah let's have a let's have a
gander Queen takes d8 I'm assuming the
same move Rook G1 he's trying to set up
the defense of the Knight on F6 Bishop
to E7 Bishop to E7
this almost feels like something's going
to go badly wrong here and he has
captured with a queen
and I have asked and look at our
producers taking care of us lifetime
matchup
s that's
a score I wouldn't have guessed that but
you know sometimes these these wow
they're a bit deceptive because of
course Wesley is younger than the bomb
so some of those victories might have
come when Wesley was
they still count
I'm sure he remembers those 15 wins all
of them uh Queen takes d8 Rook G1 rather
quickly and Bishop E7 as you said
um uh Christian uh Lavon setting up a
defense of his Knight and E3 E4 very
quickly well we what did you call it
caveman chess because the brutal F7
he wants to play E5 Drive The Night Away
expose the F7 Pawn no can do queen E8
almost forced right
but Queenie don't I have Knight takes E6
Queen E8 Knight takes E6 and in this
case Bishop takes F6 got it
out and this might be the best option
for Levon just Bishop takes F6 Queen F6
Queen F7 and europawn down but at least
you simplify the position massively wait
take take Queen F7 defend everything and
try to defend uh this type of end games
with a pawn down yeah
it's a difficult move to play though
because instinctively you'll be looking
at more active approach like for
instance well thinking of ways to try to
counter tax not
possible well here again that caveman
and he's playing Queen E8 which as you
said it does it does offer a pawn I
don't think you want to take the attack
I really don't think you want to take
that part maybe maybe
drop back and just say because that last
line where you get to go Bishop takes on
G7 Knight F3 that's an ice cold move
right there uh do we move our King
if we move our King oh dear yeah oh dear
wait a minute wait a minute I have a
problem here I may have to Simply go
back
uh Bishop takes F6 is a deadly threat
but don't they have uh Queen G5 what
about Queen
Queen
being more aggressive than that
I I love it I like uh that's the way to
the cave girl approach I like it no
Queen H6 is really really strong okay
but how realistic is it
late night F3 you've got to be ice cold
I agree with Christian but you know just
to ignore that siren there on E6 that's
like nothing to you the sirens call is
too strong for me I I cannot resist uh
if Thor himself said do not take on E6
I'd say no or you're wrong I don't think
he's going to take on E6 you think
Knight F3 I think that end game is just
too simplified okay
yeah you have the three three versus two
that's not going to be enough Knight F3
I I know it looks ugly may I play
Knight H5 Queen H6 F6
I I know it's it looks
Rook G6 Rook G6 Knight F4 no no no oh
yeah let me show you what you may have
overlooked go back go back go back go
back the game is not over the game's not
over after today you still have Queen B5
right of course of course you can defend
the night from the other the the Knight
must
hold thou shall not pass so where's the
where's the end because I have Queen F1
ideas as well yeah exactly you have to
be careful that's annoying this might
still be winning like E5 E5 yeah you go
you give me a check and I go Rook G1 oh
well he doesn't mean H4 he didn't take
the pawn the siren was not calling
oh excuse me the night remains on G5 the
queen goes to H4 it's not that we're
threatening Bishop takes F6 and queen H7
but we
are maybe threatening E5
that ass a very Salient question
I like
Queen H4 how do we meet cave girl and
can you do moves like Queen C6
okay that is a very frisky move yeah but
it's like one of those
you know whatever doesn't lose you've
got to try type of things
um F3
just
reinforcing the same uh threat of B5
I mean if you come down one day I may
just simply take this guy and take the
Rook
right you know what I mean exactly what
you mean yeah yeah oh
well everyone doesn't have too much time
to solve this problem he has a less than
two minutes on the clock
that's a practical decision that Queen
H4 not to go into that ending where
because because Lavon can play that
ending with 30 seconds yeah exactly and
this one this one is good on the fuel
yes Queen H4 big threat of E5 we're
looking at Queen C6 followed by F3 and
that clock is ticking it's now down to
one and a half minutes
here we go F2 F3 is going to come a la
tempo
Wesley
loss of time yeah so anticipating F3
which made it happen and E5
Drive oh here we go
I can go Queen C2 to defend the h no
yes we already saw that yeah yeah I saw
Queen C2 first to defend H7 then I
remembered the rook and your Euro gets
uh tapped yes on the shoulder yeah you
don't have a body anymore Queen on C6 is
not defending you you are
undefended sorry let me just refresh
apologies for that as I get uh up to
date I like I like having the uh score
of the of the moves uh in the proper
place and uh Levon under one minute
I just wondering is there a defense I
don't see anything if he doesn't see
anything what I'm going to be looking at
is just go E5 E5 E5 and then move the
Rook to a protected Square maybe the
only way yeah the only way I agree with
you
that I mean you don't play it
you you you can't allow E4 E5 and the
queen landing on H7 so Bishop takes E5
find a square d8 C8
some some square that just gets you out
of this queen
h7h8 business
and uh
hope that uh three seconds for Lavon oh
did you see the way he looked at the
clock yeah do I have a knight H7 though
uh well first of all I put the Rook on
d8 and I think you do 10 seconds I think
I'm gonna have to play rookie
A7 Rook A7 okay what is that well that
was something I wanted to do a
millennium ago uh he's defending the
bishop he's getting out of Queen A8 but
that's about all
you said Knight H7 and I'll ask the same
question as well what about Knight H7
well now with the Rook on A7 after
Knight H7 maybe you have Knight d8 moves
because the bishop only seven is
protected gotcha that that's that's very
uh pretty okay but let's try to find
something else
so we we need you to bring your bring
your Club
to the club
yes
I'm looking so the first thing is I'm
thinking about Bishop takes Knight as
you always do right and
if I can't see anything directly maybe
it's just okay relax
okay
how about just coming back from where
you were let's just go all the way and
say you know E4 E5 was a great threat a
time or two ago how about let's do it
again
I say right now Wesley is playing a
perfect game yeah is he really yes it's
just incredible he opened up the G file
G4 G5 and right now he's just taking the
most clinical approach to this position
every single move is with a purpose wow
it's not one of the children's books you
know it's like this is too cruel like
win with the collie or whatever right
okay so Rook A7 and just get the bishop
out of the way we were in and play for
E4 E5 Lavon looks like he's really
suffering uh this is it important where
you put the bishop because I was just
thinking if you go Bishop A1 maybe
there's some Bishop C five ah of course
Bishop C5
E5 takes
takes maybe I want to stop Bishop C5 and
then there's Pawn takes pawn and then
everything is protected
prove that I can go
yeah okay that's that that's a good
point then
I should stop Bishop C5 is what you mean
I should play Bishop D4 stop Bishop C5
and then press on okay let's try to be
fancy after a bishop C5 so Bishop A1
Bishop C5 let's find some fun lines I'm
sure we can do that well knife H7 ready
to make a move
how is this move 98
come on take my Rook yes sir make my day
okay okay
I'll fall for it Knight takes F6 and
Bishop takes F6 and I've got there's no
chance
I've got no check on the first rank
anymore thank you for making my day yes
yes yes
good man good to see yeah that's all I
do is I bring happiness and joy and
other lives
I am a river to my people okay Bishop
Bishop takes F6 that's unexpected that
is truly unexpected we were going in all
kinds of directions but not there okay
he's he saw something very forced now
the question is what green F4 Knight H7
is a big threat diet H7 is a huge threat
at the moment it feels like he's
sleeping a little bit right now yeah
didn't that let a what if I just take on
G5 and go G6 can I just well try to hide
like that I don't know if that's uh if
that's a joy it's not pretty it is it
definitely is not pretty but
maybe I don't have anything else well
he's doing it for it but uh no I don't
like it you've got to play juice well
unless you do know
I think Queen F6 and that end game might
be lost with those pawns but yeah it's
worth a it's worth a shot seven seconds
no F6 no F6 is very nice oh that didn't
help no no no he's got King G8 sorry EA
discovered he's got King G8 please five
seconds he's still surviving he's still
in this wow wow wow I'm not sure for
long though he's got like Rook D1 coming
look there you go on the board
a lift with his pieces you'd like you
kind of lifted up the rug yeah a lot of
people slide I'm a slider I slide the
pieces just says Rook A7 to A8 or it's a
slide
and now age four coming but guys this is
far from Clear anymore no this is not
the bishop D4 what do you have you're an
extra Pawn I mean my king might arguably
right now be safer than yours on G8
that's our argument that yeah I I don't
I wouldn't uh make because I've always
got Queen D5
if I ever felt that my king was oh
that's fine but then we make a draw most
likely right we simplify the position
more and more well I'm not sure I've got
Rook B5 uh that's going to be but I
think the McQueen E7 was designed to
stop Queen D5 suddenly because Queen D5
followed by Queen trades and Rook to B5
might be unpleasant what is a pawn up
and has got the better pieces so I don't
see how
that's about it just gonna say captain
obvious I love it
I found up in the better pieces
hang on
a queen D5 check king h8 queen D6 yeah
Wesley who's recognizing that that Rook
upon ending with the King on G3 and
Lavon same thing he's saying yeah yeah I
I hear you but Queen D7 I I'm being
persistent I like this move Queen D7 a
lot Queen G6 Queen G4 check if you go
back I've got Rook D7 and then I'm
feeling that white with the extra pawn
and the better pieces
uh
oh
again the clock is becoming a a very big
Factor he's picking up another one it's
B6 wait a minute here I am I'm the Great
Pond grubber in the family but even this
one I I had my doubts okay five check
can I go Queen E5 and Rook C2 what is
that well Queen E5 check is on the board
that's for sure what is that that well
I've got Queen d8 and Rook D2 and Rook
D2 yes that might be that might be what
Wesley is trying to do but even so where
do you put the king first okay I go H3
now Rook C2
King A3 Rook C2 Rook C2 check
King H7 and Rook D2 and our Rook D1
and now Rook D1 I'm trying to
hit everything behind yes you also have
checks as well with the queen so I I
engage
okay so this is the current position uh
Lavon to play
C3 wait a minute you're getting
dangerous a queen I would move my queen
to act two queen after Queen takes C4
Queen takes E4 I would lose careful
a check to d8 and Rook to D3
isn't that a transposition to the
position we just had probably what he
has to do yes Jack King H7 Rook to D3
no wait what is Wesley doing no no this
cannot be good good General leads his
army in the battle King G4
well he's one move away from claiming
Rook D5 would claim the game Rook 682
trying to get in a sneak in a check
times again 30 seconds for the players
bonus 30 seconds and Wesley is 34
seconds when the age of D2 what we
anticipated right a time ago though uh
but now that the king is so far away
can I go Rook C1 Rook C2 how do you
defend against that Rook just Rook C1
yeah Rook C1 so you you you're
threatening a potential Rook G one yes
so you have to block it with Rook D1 is
that that's just Rook C2 yeah that would
be a draw I'm
maybe you have to go Rook G2
well that's really seizing the defensive
isn't it but if you go Rook G2 you also
have G by the way Queen E6 checks
isn't he inviting
uh the king to just kind of come back in
into uh come back where if you go King
G2 I think what he wants is Queen B2
Queen and you go you want to go into a
queen ending yeah or one Pawn because
I'm going to take the you'll take on A2
and I think that might be enough since
you don't have a past Pawn yet
okay well uh not going to be an easy
defense even that one but at least I
have no chances so you're suggesting
King G2 oh he went King H3 and the
moment we're going to look at King G2
Queen B2 he went King H3
there's a queen E6 check isn't there
Rook C3
Rook C3 now I'm confused now I can play
King
G2 Queen F4 and rookheft and I pick up
the pawn on H on H4
might have to do it I mean the pawn on
H4 wasn't
it's not that important right it might
actually even help me a little at some
point right of the age file maybe I'll
I'll have some checks later on yeah
and he's done it
Lavon instantly said I don't need no H4
Pawn that's because he was giving up the
A5 Pawn he didn't want to see that and
he defends the A5 pawn and
says okay your turn
I would say queen D2 Queen takes D to H4
and Rook G5 Queen D2 Jovi you know he's
moved Queen D7
hesitatingly so he wants queen takes H4
Queen H3
let's trade Queens on the H file
by the way if you don't take on H4
Queen G4 he's got to and there goes the
queen trade and what's this rook and
pawn ending did Lavon scramble his way
to a potential draw it fails very close
to it right right
very close very close to it I mean I'm
not saying it's a draw right now no no
no no no but it feels very good white
White's got all of the opportunity G5 I
mean the material is so limited that
you're going to have to okay
and Rook yes yeah I like your idea but
also there's also I just want to point
Rook B2 A3 B4 is also another thing
absolutely I completely agree with that
I I like this A3 he's going for it Rook
to D2 he's threat he's this is a big
thing that's a big threat yes this is
huge that's a huge threat right now
A4 giving out the pawn
right away now this
feels should be winning how
um
I'm not convinced I'm still not
convinced I'm not convinced so you go
you take on A4 right no I'm thinking B4
sorry ah you want to go B4 yes is that
what you want to do and then go Rook B2
if I can he took you can't blame a guy
for
grabbing the pawn
I don't know okay so I I think this is
very close to a draw right now I'm not
sure suppose I play A3 Rook takes Rook
A2 but A3 I go Rook C3 Maybe
uh-huh
by the way no none of this will happen
because he played Rook D6 and A6
now the king comes in
um
King will come into age five
perhaps right now since they're down
there last like 30 seconds we can watch
the bird's eye yeah yeah I don't think
we're going to be fast enough with our
analysis anyway I love uh this still
looks winning to me he's going to play
Rook check and A7 and then the game's
getting to gc6 yes yes he is he's
getting and also King H6 and Rook B7 uh
ensures that you get to the G6 Square he
might get it guys yep he might actually
but what a labored game right truly I
mean this truly went all the way to
maybe winning for white out of the
opening Levon fighting his way
back into the game and right now with
clinical Precision seems like Wesley
might be converting this one exactly
oh 30 seconds 30 seconds for Lavon and
it's ticking down oh he touched the Rook
he has to move it what's wrong with
rookie
three well he's trying to set up some
cheap bows but hey get the pawn to A7
that's absolutely Rook check and pawn to
A7 something to be said for King H6 I'm
not sure
yeah but yeah on to A7 can't be bad I
mean that's just such a powerful Pawn
now and you know what the problem is
especially with the Rook on A4 you will
not be able to take the pawn on E3 e on
e4 excuse me with the King because I'm
always going to have ideas of Rook to B4
check
so for example King G6 King F4 I take on
F6 you take on F3 I take on G5 you
cannot take on e4 so it's Rook F7 an
idea just to stop the king getting ready
six yeah I love E7 no I actually wanted
to go for the pawns King G6
I don't know why he didn't go for that
Rook E7 check King F4 E5 is that his
idea what E5
what's if I drink I don't know five F
takes C5 I'm I'm a little curious as to
what his idea might be after King F4 it
might be that yes you might be right
um and the players after this game are
going to take a 45 minute break and
doodle all over again
hi what's Happening Here guys E6
E6
E6 King F5 you better be careful not to
get checkmated
don't get checked don't get checkmated
he's missed it by the way wait a minute
if you take on F6 I go King F5 right and
now you go King H6 only but not why G
Pawn runs this is not easy anymore 58
seconds for Levon and the table base has
popped up and it's telling us sure
Wesley has squandered the win he did
draw it's a draw
oh my word and squander the draw and the
time Advantage too
he did that with Hikaru as well
completely winning position beautiful
out playing process and right now
squanders it with low time on his clock
oh 20 seconds
what a tournament what a save you just
have to sometimes tip your hats Chapel
to to live on for sure right and now 10
seconds for Wesley well now you start to
think okay I should be making the draw
and well right be careful not to lose
this yeah be careful
he might have to at this point but six
seconds will be seven
okay okay so and actually only one way
to draw and that's actually by pushing
the G Pawn of course Levon does this
which Levon deck plays yeah and now
rugby one is his idea I was assuming
five four three two any calmly done two
seconds on the clock okay this is
basically an invitation to make a draw
yeah right
four yep yeah Rook takes and King F4 and
then you get ready to sacrifice your
Rook yeah you can take on F7 if you want
and go king of four this is this is over
well at the opening of the show we said
Thrills and Spills
and we're not being disappointed with
this one
uh you know who's disappointed Wesley is
disappointed with this tree I can
guarantee you that Rook he promoted to
her Rook by the way not to
uh
yeah
and King against King wow
sometimes wow what a save I loved your
move Rook F7 Jovi I just thought that
the one thing you don't want to see in
this position is the king coming to F4
and you spotted it right away I thought
uh Christian like King G6 but I I just
like freezing my opponent's pieces
because I think after Rook F7 King G6 is
Unstoppable and then you just make the
Harvest of the king side but let's take
a look at the results of these two very
eventful games it's very eventful and we
see here after twists and turns and yeah
surprises the game did eventually end in
a draw and the players will come back in
around about 40 minutes and do the same
again with colors reverse and then the
other elimination game oh it was a
beautiful miniature for Alice Lee
against Nazi if I keep saying Naji now
is in a must win situation with the
white piece says and I must say it was
such a one-sided gang that for Naji that
doesn't doesn't even count let's just
put it down she's got to come back
forget all about it and win with the
white pieces but as we uh get ready uh
we have Christian with a very very
special guest in studio a certain Mr
rexingfield very special guest indeed
the co-founder of the Saint Louis chess
club Mr Rex sinfield Rex first of all
welcome to the show we've had so many
amazing matches so far oh it's been
incredible and we've had the best
commentary in the world of all time
we're always nice about that thank you
very much I'm always honest about it
what was your favorite match oh I'll put
you on the spot
I guess it would be one of the games
with Fabi well this last one was
interesting but it was pretty clear it
was editorial draw that match I would
assume is the one that went all the way
to Armageddon yes between himself and
Levon now tell us a bit about this
format because I know you have your
doubts but right now no I like it and
I've been querying many people and I
haven't seen anybody that doesn't like
it some of them have a little trouble
understanding it at first and that's
understandable especially if you're in
the midst of it but I think it's
generated a lot of excitement and it
hasn't been used very often so people
are saying why don't we try it in all of
our other tournaments well that's a bit
you know a bit much but if you would
play in the tournament uh which time
control do you think would suit you the
best uh if my opponent got no time
yes guys join the conversation
that's fair Rex I tell you one of the
things that's bugging me about the St
Louis chess club these days is uh the
the renovation let's let's face it the
renovation has been ongoing for the
better part of a year I know the
pandemic
but I have seen the designs and they're
beautiful and so I'm anxious for the
club to meet the expectations that
everybody has when is it going to happen
well thank you for your anxiety
we're all frustrated too it's been going
on it's like
age-old had never I I don't say it
doesn't come to an end because it hasn't
begun and that's the frustration we have
all the contracts signed all the
approvals from the city and we just
can't seem to get the contractors to
move that's the frustration I see so
that's the hold up because the the
designs are beautiful I mean it's going
to be it's going to be the most
beautiful chess club uh well certainly
America's ever seen but we want to say
uh the world
probably in the world but I haven't gone
to see all of them
next time I was curious to know what is
the big ambition for St Louis chess club
it's hard to hear what is the big
ambition for the Saint Louis jazz club
she's asking oh my goodness because you
guys have already done so I think they
just keep doing the things we've been
doing it would be nice someday to hold a
world championship here but I think we
have to have a St Louis participant to
justify that
Rex congratulations for this amazing new
tournament the American Cup at the world
chest Hall of Fame there's also the
music series happening every week tell
us a bit about that that happens twice a
month we have one pop Series
so it can be Seoul it can be jazz or
whatever and then we have one classical
series which I will admit is my favorite
and we often borrow performers from the
St Louis Symphony and uh these folks
really know their tune they're
outstanding I have to say I've been to
some of those shows they're just simply
remarkable Jovi you have something for
us as we go on a break yes we do because
the World Chess Hall of Fame sponsors a
fantastic music series with a short
break in the American cup action we are
happy to show you a couple of
performances first up music director
Brian Woods performs enjoy the concert
and we'll resume our coverage of the
American Cup shortly
good evening everyone welcome my name is
Brian Woods I am music director here at
the World Chess Hall of Fame it is my
pleasure to welcome you to tonight's
concert featuring myself and violinist
Daniel dostor I would be remiss if I did
not first thank Dr Jeannie and Rex
sinkfield for their incredible support
of this series
[Applause]
we are also grateful to the regional
Arts commission and the Missouri Arts
Council for their support do check out
the exhibit that is finishing just next
month here at the roll chest Hall of
Fame at uh Bobby Fischer Boris Bosque
1972 celebrating a pivotal match in
chess history it's going away so go see
it now I would also encourage you to
check out season tickets which are here
for the music series and please check
that out you are going to get all kinds
of discounts and we are only selling 24
of these for members so check that out
it's a huge amount of savings look in
your program you get all the perks you
can get there I can't go through all of
them but it's a lot so I would check
that out
and uh be sure to check out worldchess
hof.org that's where you can learn about
all of our offerings here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame and everything we
have coming up including some of our
next concerts including the Opera
theater of St Louis season preview next
month don't miss that
so it is my pleasure to open tonight's
concert we are opening with the violin
Sonata of Francisco a French composer
this piece was written during 1943
during the Nazi occupation of Paris it's
a very violent piece It Was Written in
honor of a guitarist friend of his who
had passed away so you can hear in the
second movement I'm doing my best guitar
impression up here as best I can and
it's full of colors full of rhapsodic
Melodies and full of drama so please
join me in welcoming here on stage
violinist Daniel Doster
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody
[Music]
Daniel's fetching some rosin for his for
his bow so I'm going to continue to
entertain you and now I'm kidding
um anyone know any good jokes
um the next piece in the program is
um a real uh it's completely different
as maybe Monty Python I'd say not to
something completely different we're
going to have a showpiece from Fritz
Chrysler who is as people say the
violinists violinist this is peace uh
piece incredible violin uh technique and
pyrotechnics you're going to hear as I
sort of bump along although Daniel would
argue otherwise but this piece is the
Viennese Rhapsody
and it's uh in honor of when Chrysler
moved here to the states actually during
the same time that the pool was written
he was missing his home in Vienna back
in Austria so this is a piece that is
very Fantastical very virtuosic very
exciting but also very reminiscent of
Austrian walls that you might hear on
New Year's Eve so please enjoy
hey foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
forever
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
no no no no
no no no
no no
no no no no no no
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
he can play folks he can play
um thank you all so much for being here
um Daniel is a good friend for those who
are not here for the pre-concert chat we
met at the Royal Conservatory of Music
in Toronto during the peak of the 2020
pandemic and he was the first person
that I made music with following the
pandemic so we have a very special tight
relationship as um collaborators as as
artistic partners and it's it's really a
special a special thing for us so uh the
final piece in the program is something
that many classical fans might be a fan
of this is the Brahms D Minor violin and
piano Sonata Opus 108 this is a
um staple of the Romantic piano and
violin repertoire and you'll notice it
is a Sonata for piano and violin not
violin and piano Brahms wrote it
specifically that way my part is rather
meaty so there's a lot going on on this
piece the first movement it has this
incredibly beautiful violin opening over
a very ghostly pale piano underpinning
and then the second movement I we were
saying in the pre-confer chat is is the
most intimate expression of love for
someone whether that be a romantic
partner or a family member or something
it's very special and the third movement
is very Whimsical Fantastical uh you
know full of full of trists and turns
Sparkle and the final movement is a tour
de force for both of us so you have that
to look forward to so please enjoy
Brahms synonym number three
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to this eventful day seven
where we are going to be deciding who is
going to go through to the Grand Final
yes so far it's been a very eventful
start and this game well it had us all
on tender hooks but in the in in the end
Levon aronians is kind of proving to us
he's got nine lives
exactly and he escaped from well he
escaped with a draw against Wesley so
and in the other elimination bracket
final it was a very quick victory for 13
year old Alice Lee with the white pieces
leaving Naji pakiza in a must win
situation let's just visit the brackets
once one more time to show everybody
what we're expecting Irina crashes
waiting for the winner she is waiting
for the winner and in the Champions
bracket and it's all been completed it
is Arena Crush who was Victorious and
also netted her yourself a five thousand
dollar Champions bracket bonus very
nicely done and in the open section in
the open section whoops not yet not
quite ah okay here we go and here we go
in the elimination bracket whoa whoa
whoa whoa okay uh Wesley so as you were
saying uh he snatched a draw from the
jaws of Victory yes he did he he did a
very impressive style and he lives
another day and talking about another
day well it's another game really and
everything will be decided today
absolutely and the winner will go up
against one Hikaru Nakamura and uh here
you can see Hikaru Nakamura is the
winner of
fight straight to the Grand Final and
has also gotten there with an extra ten
thousand dollars in his pockets and how
are our friends at qbt we do have a
special performance Community it is the
special and uh bring home a piece of
Chess history with this autographed
wooden board signed by all the American
Cup players it comes with a certificate
of authenticity and it's available now
exclusively at
cubiteesstl.com and that is an
incredible prizes and you can have a
look at all those signatures
that was clear some of them are
squiggles some of them and wow what a
nice little imprint there I've got the
Saint Louis St Louis chess club at this
these boards will worth a lot of money
they are if it's on a special go there
to cubitec and get it now Naji is going
to have to win with the white pieces as
she faces elimination and Wesley so
levona ronian having drawn their first
game uh well we're almost gonna have to
ask our audience uh whether they think
it's going to go to uh
Blitz or not right or it would be an
accelerated yes so if the score is tied
then the players play a two-game match
at the time control of 10 minutes plus
five seconds okay and if it's still tied
we're gonna see a blitz tie break or
three minutes plus two seconds and then
finally after all these games are chess
still tired and uh Christian the rumor
on the street has it that Lavon jumped
on his bicycle uh during the break uh to
just get rid of some energy I did not
hear that but I wouldn't be surprised
that's one thing that uh even when he
came to the studio and talked to us he
was saying that this is his main focus
he just wants to stay ready from a
physical perspective but also a mental
right whenever you play this type of
like super tense games and then do you
go back home and look at your lines
continue looking at chess or do you want
to get a fresh perspective and this is
exactly what Levon
um emphasized he said yes I want to get
a fresh perspective I want to take a
walk in the park see the trees get some
vitamin D you know breathe fresh air
things of that nature and that's going
to give me a clear mind as I go into
this very tense battles against the best
chess players on the planet one thing
that he can do put pressure on his
opponent's clock we've seen that this
seems to be the weakness in Wesley's
armor in this particular event whenever
he gets down to his last 20 30 seconds
he starts taking timid decisions we've
seen that when he played against Hikaru
yesterday in the first rapid playoff
we've seen it in the first game of this
particular match against Levon aronian
as well so in my estimation this is what
Levon needs to do take him down to the
last few minutes with a complicated
position and then I think he would be
the favorite in those type of situations
otherwise I have to say Wesley has been
impressing with his opening preparation
with his middle game play
he is able to Outfox his opponents he's
very very experienced and very strong
opponents but once again whenever he
gets down to those last few seconds he
starts to work yeah some wobbly
decisions and of course coming up uh
Sunday we're going to have a very
special uh tournament a nine round Blitz
tournament Swiss style yes and there'll
be no draw offers because door offers
are not allowed in St Louis we like
Fighting Chess and the time control of
three minutes plus two seconds nine
rounds and it includes some of the
strongest players in the world also
known as those players from the local
universities and eliminated American Cup
participants expecting 40 really really
really top players those this is going
to be the type of tournament where you
could lose to a Lavon and your next
opponent could be a Wesley so it's not
a pleasant experience when everybody's
so strong that that should be a fun
event keep that in mind on your calendar
Sunday March 26th as Wesley is at the
board waiting for Lavon who appears to
just coming in to view now
um
again I was a little bit surprised from
the uh head-to-head match in the Rapids
we showed their scores Wesley has won 10
times the fact that Levon had won 15
times was a bit of surprise I thought
that it was going to be more even than
that but that's a significant difference
as they're underway D4 D5
E4 sorry
yeah we have the wrong game up exactly
the Petra from Wesley really hmm
I I don't remember last time I've seen
Wesley play the Petrov
it's uh D3 probably probably this is
what kind of convinced Wesley to try the
Petrov is that he felt that uh the white
players in the tournament have not been
getting
really any kinds of advantages that to
speak of and remember LaVon in his
classical game played this system too he
didn't get anything no and also he also
his game against linear Dominguez
yesterday was the Petrov which
was it came in 11 came with some nice
ideas but at the same time it did also
not entirely feel it wasn't 100 no
convincing and it's already different
from that one because in that one linear
defended the Knight only four with D5
and allowed at the pawn sacrifice after
E1 exactly now this makes perfect sense
to to my eyes D5 and I would probably be
putting this light Square Bishop uh on
the G4 Square after all after H3 Bishop
H5 you really don't want to play G4 I I
can imagine players who do play the move
G4 but okay that you you take a little
strategic risk so uh we'll keep an eye
on this one as I don't see it as a big
theoretical debate going on here per se
and jump to the game again Naji must win
with the white pieces against Alice Lee
and as they get started let's see what
uh Naji has done what I say the point on
G4 semi-slav
yeah G4 okay uh that's one way that
that's one way to mix it up okay H7 H6
h2h3 I mean to say uh not exactly the
follow-up that you might anticipate if
you play a move like G4 what are you
playing for well you're playing for G5
Rook H Rook G1 H4 G5 might have been
more enterprising H3 uh B7 B6 and that's
it which is no I no they've taken
they've taken on D5 C takes D5 and the
main move is actually to capture with
the e-pawn really intriguing
so in this case since I've played the
move G4 I know where I'm going I'm going
to go uh queenside with the move Bishop
D2 castles
um wasn't it yesterday that Arena Crush
was playing this setup as white against
Alice Lee where she ended up castling
she did costly inside but I'm in there
Alice was short yes
then came yes that's right then came G5
and H5 right it was good but there's a
big difference though because uh in
Arena's game against honestly Arena
managed to get her Bishop out to F4 and
make some trades and the bishop came out
to D3 here the queen is that sat there
on C2 not as aggressive two not as
aggressive right but on the other hand
you know White's intentions are very
clear yes uh you're right she did play
the move E6 it takes D5 not c665 and
again I'm anticipating Bishop do I guess
Queen E7 Bishop D3 I will as White
Castle long and then I'm hoping that my
opponent will Castle shorts so that G5
is right on time right on schedule you
know uh not going to happen I suspect
Alice will also match her opponent on
the king but how excited how do you
measure yes and I us will be feeling in
a solid mood because of course a win or
Draw and she moves on to the Grand Final
where she will be facing Arena
Let's uh take it one more at a time
could you start with Bishop D2 I go
Queen E7 I go Bishop to T Bishop D3 yeah
how does black continue right now
because whenever you play c57 you should
be seven and let's go Castle long long
castle Yeah Yeah and until
if you copy that's what I was really oh
you you want to go Knight B5 but maybe
five Bishop B8 right yes it's just a
temporary thing right yeah I thought I
was playing for E3 E4 and I was actually
planning to play rookie one so you want
to Castle long that that makes sense
that definitely makes sense let's put it
another way I definitely don't want to
go into the hurricane
that you've got ready for me over there
yeah I mean come on you'll rip open the
king side and I will be uh I'll be in
deep trouble yep no yeah it's but it
looks good right if you want to play for
a win as white exactly imbalance that
you want to have on the board and I have
to comment
um Nazi for this because she's been
really out foxing her opponents out of
the opening especially with the white
pieces we've seen it with her Catalan
against the tonsky Catalan against
Beckham she got the winning position
yesterday and we're seeing once again
that she's getting a better position out
of the opening against what is a very
well prepared opponent at least Lee
that's actually one of her best assets
Alice is that is her opening preparation
but still Nazi got a better position
well in that first game it was a very
clever
uh opening play by
najibichi ended up overlooking a huge
tactical bomb that just destroyed her
position but it was clever of her to get
this whole
um King Bishop takes C3 Queen E17 d8 to
C7 it just didn't work out yeah Knight
H4 that looks a little bit
peculiar and mistimed uh what do you
think about this movie it was
interesting exactly maybe it's got the
idea is to actually you know threaten to
come in with F5 sure encouraging black
to park the canyon the king side which
is where that ready-made attack is
brewing I don't know me gusta I don't
like putting my king over there I would
never do that and I I would I would kind
of get ready to meet Knight F5 I don't
know if uh if this move Knight to f8 and
Knight to E6
uh is suitable for the occasion but
again I'm I'm not a fan of just dropping
the GPS tactics Knight takes D5 yeah
yeah yeah yeah I know you're my Spidey
Sense began tingling as well as well uh
Queen takes C6
oh okay so does it mean that I have to
just
drop that oh no I don't want to be doing
this because no Queen will come to see
the queen doesn't have the nice E7
Square well yeah my next move will be
the G6 G7 G6 to
kick you back
what if I go E4 even though E4 maybe a
bit mistoned okay uh I think this is a
bit misdaily a little bit you're not so
sure yeah okay let's get ready for it
Bishop G2 maybe bishop to D3 and then at
the right moment that will play E4 okay
but now I kind of feel like okay my
Bishop got booted from D6 by Queen will
still go to E7
um intriguing Knight H4
all right well it's certainly achieved
one goal and that is
stopped stop and think yeah that is for
sure a quick question for you you
capture are you in aggressive mood well
it's about me because uh Naji is the one
playing and she is in an aggressive mood
you think she will sacrifice yes let's
have a look
well
I mean she went Knight H4 and if I go
King f8 I can understand
the sacrifice really right away if I go
King E7 Jack and you have to step up
with the King uh this is not
what Alice has in mind is it so you you
we we would likely see a variation like
this and yeah that's that's two pawns
and an attack exactly I wouldn't want to
uh this will not be wanting this time
no G6
okay let's keep going with that because
um yeah you guys are passing through but
I'm not convinced you're not convincing
me
our Jedi Mind Tricks are no longer
working on Christian bad signs king of
Fate King f8 E4 now I go Queen E8 Queen
Edgar eight Bishop say spawn you take
Pawn I go kingy seven oh
check
we hide
go to d8 now oh we don't get them
no I was going to play E5 Bishop f8 I
take a rook
oh wait wait wait wait yeah
but you could go Rook G8 yes you can I
didn't want to tell him that by the way
thank you
I knew I got him I just didn't see it
you just didn't see how or why or
anything uh
hmm okay Queen E8 was that too fast Joe
V with my after Queen E8 should I I take
this guy yeah he can do that and how is
that position I think back with the
Knight you take on D5 yeah but that's
three pawns you have a lot of Pawns yes
it's not no that's not convincing to my
eyes just a second
um no Queen F5 just okay beautiful I
think Bishop takes H6 feels good that
certainly does okay now and I think here
is where maybe now you take on E8 right
okay
that feels a little bit better yeah
what do I take back with you well if you
take with the King I've got Bishop to G7
and take the Knight and you're you're
you're beautifully set up for E5
if you take with the Knight well then
we've got the same position but then I
have snuck off with the three pawns and
likely before yes yeah four might
actually be enough to give you the
advantage right and if you take with the
Rook well then you have E55 and King
goes and
probably Bishop E3 bishop and it's good
for white it's good for a white yeah
hmm okay so probably G6
perhaps too much yeah our Jedi Mind
Tricks
we really had to focus for a while there
but yeah okay uh but by the way Alice
Lee is still in uh in the things here I
think which is uh an indication that
Naji is once again a fox ter opponent
let's jump to the other
um elimination game
after D5 we did see the move d4 no
Bishop G4 rookie eight okay very useful
move C4 Knight C6 Knight C3 H6 H3 takes
takes Bishop D6 takes takes
somehow this looks like it's still
Mainline Theory
and it is it is it is okay I wouldn't
say it's Main Line because um
Bishop F1 are not exactly yes but it has
been played before so okay and what have
the results uh yielded can you guess
draws correct yeah two games two drawers
just a second let me congratulate myself
on how deep understanding and it's very
very hard to get advantages in these
isolated queen palm positions uh is
white I mean the fact that the piece the
board is still full of pieces is a good
sign for white he wants to keep as many
minors on the on the board as possible
by the way uh Lavon must have seen the
game of Najee and when Knight H4
good good good plan
uh Knight H4 looks a little bit
strange to my eyes Bishop back
uh
I mean if your knight comes to F5 Mazel
Tov but if it doesn't well I think this
is what he wants probably between the
queen of three yeah sorry Queen F3 tried
to get that Knight to F5 okay I'll try
oh Bishop takes H6 no I got my takes D4
so let's try to get ready for that
before sorry Bishop B5
Rook D1 rookie eight can I take on H6
now yes I was wondering about this
you've got
uh Bishop F1
I do no trickies here but you've got
Bishop H2
I mean it's a complex there's a lot of
trickies here I mean this guy's hanging
this guy's hanging and it's like Queen G
three minor pieces are hanging but I can
defend most of them with Queen G3 right
then you have Knight H5 wow okay that's
some that's this is a complex line I
very unclear yeah you you need to
calculate that one pretty carefully and
if you were to kind of play the position
position League sorry like okay Bishop
B5
threaten uh Queen F3 Queen D7 because
and now Bishop B5 so then after a6u yes
just forced
before yeah yeah and then if you
yeah okay you want to try it yeah I
wanted to trade but then you know I'm
thinking the position is way too open
after Queen takes I've got good
compensation with the two Bishops okay
you tricked me here sir well done just a
second I take 186 out there Queen David
seven you take on H6 and you're not
worried about this well now I take on B7
that attacks The Rook
okay but
whoa whoa whoa whoa who whoa whoa whoa
Queen takes
tickles The Rook
wow
not many squares for the queen but
not so easy to attack her either Queen
by the way they're following
here it comes Bishop takes H6
Knight okay so this is the current
position and we've been looking at the
move Bishop takes H6 which
again is very attractive because first
of all you win a pawn and you're
threatening Queen takes F6 in case you
capture so Knight takes D4 in order to
kick the queen away and takes and I'm
assuming rookie eight and now the bishop
has to go right
the question is where well
E3 will just invite C Knight C2 so
Bishop to G5 let's try it out
hmm well it's an extra pawn and it's
putting a very serious question to
Wesley where's your compensation
Jovi where's the compensation
okay I like
there's definitely some compensation
right I mean that Queen is not having
very very clear spots so Knight takes C4
Bishop takes E4 my guess is that's what
I meant when I said the queen doesn't
really have a lot of squares I cannot
take on A7 because of Rook A8 and that
is a very nice and very well known uh
pattern of a discover check so that's a
problem
ouch
ouch I have to shy away to go Queen A6
and this feels like it's worth a pawn
because so many offside pieces but hey
you know guys like me will ask you to
prove it right and that's the problem I
mean I would love to come forward with
the queen right the night on age four
yeah
I mean I'd love to go Queen F5 you like
to go F6 and G5
this night is so because this night is
so
um
offsides maybe I have to play an ugly
move like Bishop E7 just temporary to
try to exploit
be offside night
well Lavon is not eager to go for the
pawn he is not reaching for H6
and what would be
an alternative though Queen D7
I can and he's not he's done it he took
a challenge
I was about to ask was there an
alternative to Bishop takes H6 I didn't
really see a good one
I could play Rook D1 but rookie eight
and then I'm asking myself why did I put
my knight on H4
if I'm not playing for Knight F5
okay Knight takes D4
has to be played looks like a queen
takes B7 Rook E8
one of the things that we've been
talking about in these time controls is
the initiative
oftentimes In classical chess you've got
the time to neutralize an initiative and
sometimes you're eager to take the
material with less time you're seizing
the defensive and giving your opponent
the attack is not always a very good
strategy uh the attack is it's it's
easier to play than the defense I agree
I I but then you know it depends on your
style I have to say I'm gonna put a
condition on that statement because some
players are just really good at
defending and they say they find it
easier because all they're just doing is
like looking at the opponents or moves
and just thinking how can I survive and
the goal is very much on a short-term
basis and there's no pressure because
after all if you lose you lose yeah I'm
a I'm a provocateur I like
um
forcing my opponent to sacrifice and
maybe some opponents are very
comfortable sacrificing I never Force
told the sacrifice anything against me
like no no no no no other opponents
really don't like giving up the material
and sometimes you make the right choice
but here we here we have it uh Wesley uh
being asked to make the sacrifice Bishop
takes H6 and Knight takes D4 Queen takes
B7 and uh Christian uh what does the
engine think about these tactics the
engine is saying that black is okay
black is okay yes author and I think
it's D4 you have to take that pawn yep
take it back Queen B7 rookie eight yeah
we were actually on the right path yep
and now Bishop G5 is in fact quite a bad
move really okay because of this move
Knight to E4 right and the line that we
went through Knight takes Bishop takes
Queen A6 not Queen takes A7 because I
Rook to A8 right in A6
and Bishop to E7 and it gives black a
decisive advantage yeah I decided the
night on H4 was
offside right you need to right take
advantage but how do you do it let's
let's keep going let's keep going let's
try to understand why
because it's still not clear I take on
E7
you take back with the queen
and what if I just defend
G3 I know it looks horrendous
yeah that's a problem
that's that's uh six Knight F3 can it
doesn't feel right no it just simply
doesn't feel right no it does not yeah
you're giving up yeah yeah
um if Bishop G5 is wrong you have to go
Bishop E3 which allows Knight to C2 but
that was that was the one thing I didn't
want to do because there I really felt
that the
um compensation was indisputable it is
but you can force the trade of the
Queens I can with Bishop B5 yes
say what with Bishop B5
okay so after Knight C2 I start with
Bishop B5 should be five yes gotcha so
that force is Queen CA gotcha Queen C8
we exchanged the queens and then we go
into this end game in which after I pick
up the bishopone E3 I have the two
Bishops with an open Center
it seems like this should be enough
compensation for the pawn wow
by the way we do have Knight takes D4
Queen takes B7 Rook E8 on the board and
Bishop E3 and Bishop E3 as well yes yes
okay so these guys aren't good
took us a little while to work through
the complications uh but we did manage
to get here and the whole point is
Knight C2 Bishop B5
when your kings under attack Jovi's
Golden Rule trade the Queens it's a
great rule it is a great times out of
10. it will work it will work you know
take take the attacking the most potent
attacker the Queen off the board Knight
C2 and uh it's clear that uh you'd like
this queen is actually
going to be attacked but this one Queen
C8 Queen takes C8 Rook takes C8 Rook
here and poof
once again it yeah well we see Knight C2
they're going all the way down our main
line Bishop to C5
I'm not I'm not sure I like this whole
night H4 business but okay we'll see
let's turn our attention to the other
elimination game and uh you'll see that
Naji has come to this game in an
incredible fighting mood Holy Spirit
look at that that's the one two three
four pawn attack well surprise surprise
both players decided to uh go kingside
uh Knight H4 Bishop B7 Alice played
Knight
F5 G6 we kind of saw this ah F2 F4
now she castled Mission T2
what B5
that's I think she thought that if she
was stopping E4 because then of course
you're gonna go B4 but wow I mean
normally speaking this bishop on B7
needs a better View and you usually play
C5 in order to x-ray the E4 Square B5
looks a little bit peculiar to my eyes
E4 and what you're about to say is if
Alice followed through with her before
you would be rather of the Mind hey look
I'm really happy I got this Pawn on E5
and I'm going to win my piece back but
the fact that this bishop is not sitting
on the G7 Square
[Music]
very far away from the action as well
exactly but it's not looking good yeah
I'm I'm thinking you know F4 F5 The
Bishop's gonna land on H6 which is why
we saw takes
and I'm assuming
well this is one of those moments where
these top guys and I don't understand
exactly why they do it but these top
guys oftentimes play a move like rookie
one they don't even take the pawn right
and and it makes you stop and you know
you are all ready to play Knight takes
E4 yourself and now you can't understand
why they did it the way they did it but
it works out uh Knight takes E4 which
night
this one
okay
three is the magic number by the way the
top guys we were just we were just
talking about the stuff guys when it
comes to attacking pieces three is the
magic number you want to attack the
black sorry the king
with three yeah that's that's the magic
number yeah huff and puff and blow your
house down three yeah three and you've
got to remember that like this is very
easy three wise men Three Little Pigs
I'm still working on the Jovi Golden
Rule you know you know you don't want to
you don't want to overwhelm me here with
this Christian Jump Right In she played
rookie1 wow I mean she's been studying
the top players games rookie E1 do I
have time to go C5
yes uh but
are you inviting tactics I'm inviting
everything I mean I don't that might
look it's not looking good I'm not
saying
yeah I know I was just thinking so if
you go can you get away with it because
that is key all right it's just after
you went C5 I thought let's calculate
yes well there's some trickies in the
position that attracted which Pawn would
you like to take
the pawn I would like to take is H6 I
would love to get an F4 F5 and H Bishop
takes H6 you're not very far away from
it that's exactly my thinking as well
I'm almost thinking
D5 divide because okay uh I would like
to keep as many attackers on the board
as possible and if you were to capture
this Pawn this is where my F5 Bishop H6
fantasy
may become a reality one thing that I
can tell you about this position is
Nazi's playing confidently and to be
honest visually she's got the perfect
overwhelming absolutely I mean look at
how many pieces I have
swarming around your King right this
knight from C3 is going to come join the
join the action during The Fray which
one D2 is going to get opened after F5
those pawns threatening
I agree it does look completely scary
visually but then you know
I'll never forget your words you're
doing some commentary and what did I say
let me start doing a repair job
a repair job I never I have a producer
Tommy and he will fight for me he will
never we will when did I ever repair
and did it work it did I I just remember
it was when I got into it yeah and I
thought that's such a lovely expression
so when I'm in trouble when I'm in like
Crisis management mode I think of those
words repair job you know let me try to
put some pieces towards the king let me
try to plug the holes okay so rookie one
so rookie one how are you going to do
the repair where where do you start
there's a lot to repair
you kind of want the bishop on G7 but
that's you know that
yeah that's not getting the G7 anytime I
was thinking about moves like Bishop out
to be Bishop
okay I cannot resist I I told you I
warned you I did I know yeah but there
was nothing I could do to be frank okay
so now I have to just close the position
up because if G5 G5 I know I know I know
it's this is
blast yes this is not the best repair no
I I understand that I mean it looks
terrible but then again you know I have
to keep it going and she played after
beef okay sorry let me just repeat Let
me just refresh I apologize I'm Bishop
C7
94 Knight takes E4 I know probably
before well for sure and that uh
remember to invite everybody uh to the
party tonight takes E4 looks
good somehow even Bishop takes E4 I know
everything sounds kind of looking good
but 94 makes the most sense I mean you
have a clear threat that is Knight C5
you have a lot of ideas in the position
it doesn't seem like black has good
defenses what about a F5 you know I
don't know why I don't know why I've
kind of taken the role of Defense
I like you as the attacker trust me on
this one yeah F5 is forcing me to go yep
nice takes E4 and this is the problem
there's there's a dual threat there's
Knight C5 with a discovery against the
queen
followed by Knight takes B7 and along
with Knight C5 I consider the move F4 F5
frankly deadly totally yeah when I play
the move F5 and I slap Bishop takes H6
that's a catastrophe
for Naji this is like a dream come true
I mean she has to win she trails in the
match one nil uh after a disastrous
first game and this looks like a
disastrous first game second game for
Alice oh he's looking great for Naji
yeah so how do you define you you get
the queen to d8 right even if you go to
d8 you have to run away as
as gorgeous it's not pretty I understand
that I don't think the repair I don't
think no I don't see any chances of
repair on this one and I have to go C5
and try to do something yeah
can't I just crunch munch crunch can
definitely do that next night is forced
and let me pick up that guy before I go
Queen F5
although I must say queen F5 looked very
compelling as well I'm sorry this is i i
as a good trainer I gotta throw in the
towel here for Alice she played it she
played Queen d8 but Queen you guys
mentioned F5 is just tremendous right
now in the position It's Shouting It's
shouting out
um wow a couple of times in these
matches I I've seen it's the hardest
thing in the world to win a winning
position
but to win on demand are you kidding me
that's really really tough and I've been
seeing a couple of players somehow
managing and I mean I'm talking Wesley
so I'm talking Fabiana Carlo I'm
dropping Lavon aronian
these guys went on demand and uh this is
impressive F5 as he's got a fabulous
look at this this rook's not in the game
everything from White is ideal Bishop on
B7 Bishop on C7 looked too passive F5
yeah I I agree I mean it just looks over
completely
um devastating for whites I mean the
only thing that I can see is that you
know you maybe don't compromise the
king-size porn structure maybe King H7
but you know if if I survive this
five moves I would be happy exactly
exactly F5 on the board in Alice
understands uh completely well that
things have gone
you know off the off the tracks that's
an incredible response by Nazi by kids
yeah with her back against the wall to
do this right to start off with this G4
H3 F4 E4 D4 I mean yeah she's really
impressive psychological game I've
noticed that you know she really has
chosen her openings well she's decided
okay this is gonna unsettle my opponents
this is their weakness and I've noticed
you know her approach with the black
pieces and with the white is always very
direct and uh Knight F6 right F6 I told
you that Bishop takes H6 with uh my
dream that's the smell of desperation
exactly
um
[Music]
in the air for black that's a check of
course but Knight takes F6 Queen takes
F6
F5 takes G6 compels you to recapture
with the queen uh
unfortunately
uh there's too many attractive moves and
sometimes you you kind of get caught up
in you know uh you know which one to
choose here I would probably just go
Bishop takes H6 myself
but this one
and she's done it f takes G6
she's looking at
F takes G6 Knight C5 this is the old
double attack
and
that is really great Queen takes D4 I
have the defense with Bishop E3
precisely so
you go Queen D6 you
try to say that you have some sort of
check Queen taste G6 check uh-uh
too much overwhelming overwhelming and
after King to h8 let's keep on taking
some pawns exactly you can't afford to
trade Queens by interposing the Knight
so all right so how do we do it now
I was the one I wouldn't want to go
Queen G5 defending the night and then
before Bishop F4 yeah that thing
can I just ask please what's the problem
with like Rook F5 no problem no problem
that's a very see you're a natural
aggressor
attacker no no don't play those
defensive moves to get the repair shop
just go to Just Go For the Kill yeah
yeah that's that's uh that's that's
impressive
absolutely devastating right now right
Knight C5 we're expecting for Naji and
we'd like that move up still Bishop H6
also looks good yeah no this looks very
very good I just have to check with our
other
and the players got to the very position
and
um well Lavon oh let me just make sure
that that's true
uh that could be in an analysis by the
way no no it wasn't the players are they
actually laying down right down the
Primrose path
coughed out yep Rook B1 B3 Rook
isn't that interesting we just saw not
Bishop takes E3 but Rook E1 and we just
saw on the Alice Lee game not Knight
takes E4 but rookie won preparing the
threat is stronger than the execution
right
nice uh in this particular case what
what did Wesley accomplish with the move
Rook B1 Rook B8 pardon me b2b3 the
Knight is no longer protected it's that
simple so now he wants Rook E8 so that
he can play Rook takes E3 or okay it is
on the board King takes H7 and now
he didn't play Rook to D3
okay and take this ending okay so the E3
Pawn is going to fall off that's uh
correct certainty in life but uh
I see that this position you know black
has those two isolated pawns on the
queen side split balance yes yeah
and does is that something that white
can use
it yeah yeah
in the theory upon Islands yes that's
exactly what uh uh Lavon would do
normally when I when I have the rook and
Bishop combination versus a rook and
Knight combination I'm not anxious to
trade Rooks so in this particular case I
would probably go for something of
Bishop takes E3 with the idea that maybe
my rook and my bit excuse me my rook and
maybe my Bishop could somehow
work uh together in conjunction with it
and Wesley did not trade Rooks he did
Play Bishop takes E3 and I would expect
the bishop to go back to cover the split
pawns and to prepare Rook C5 let's go
back to the other uh game because uh the
move Knight C5 we think is a stone cold
winner in between Naji and Alice but it
hasn't happened yet it hasn't has been
appeared on the board yet nine minutes
and 40 seconds for Nazi by kids that
right now 9 minutes and 49 seconds for
Alice Lee but
in a very very difficult position Knight
C5 wins on the spot she needs to find it
there will you have it
from you exactly
from your lips to her hand Knight to C5
we always thought that King G6 the
players are connected to the broadcast
that's why I've always tried to keep my
voice at an even Cadence players didn't
uh
because the number of times they copy my
move I mean that's just not
mathematically yeah
I don't know whether it was you but
there were two commentators who were
doing like a world championship
commentary and everyone was listening to
them in the auditorium they had the
headphones plugged in but the problem
was that these two commentators were too
funny yes and the audience just like
they're chuckling right yeah that was me
that was you so it was the the 1990
World Championship Match in New York
City
and there was an audience of about a
thousand people and they had their
headsets on and the Arbiters kept coming
out and hitting the silent silence quiet
quiet these people are rolling in the
aisle because I was making a bet with
all my commentators and uh PT Barnum the
fool is uh you know born every second
and
I was losing bets every word all of my
colleagues and I was like okay another
one another one another 20 on you you
know like where's my chips where's my
receipts the audience lost it I got
kicked out of the auditory it was great
I went to a VIP lounge oh that was
Marvel's anyway it was great knight C5
what did we have after Knight C5 Queen
takes before Bishop E3 this is where we
had that no this is not that's our she
played Queen E5 25 to try to take that
G5 Square well queen that isn't that
even worse because because doesn't that
work walk Head Over Heels Into The Rook
at five move well I yeah
five looks good yeah
by the way you might want to start with
Queen takes H6 first that's right I I
like the King on h8 because I was
feeling but he can't take it back just
Queen takes G6 and here's the money move
you think Queen H6 you can take it first
and then well ah you mean Knight H7
Bishop okay Bishop D4 instantly I get
you yeah in that case I'm grubbing upon
you're right what do you mean Bishop D4
well if you go Knight H7 which was
Bishop takes D4 Queen takes D4 well what
is that
oh it's not perfect it's not projected
Jovi you're supposed to be my group you
gotta protect me from myself
as well
it's the Jedi mind trick I'm telling you
it works three times even though my
co-host
you can try it only once for a broadcast
that's what I Naji came
to this game with a single-minded focus
of just winning that's it Rook F5 I love
that go ahead play Queen H2 which she
has done to move the king to F1 Bishop
d4's on her agenda and the King on h8 is
is over Benito he's game over absolutely
what a bounce back wow
that's only a 2d sacrifice it's also we
check right thank you very much okay
should
win and we think it's pretty uh clear
they're gonna go play another uh two
games
there'll be a break there will be a big
break a big break really another hour
well we're going to come back at 5 30
p.m oh my well that wasn't the short for
some reason I had it in my mind today
might be a short day of uh games but uh
no no no no
because there's a big break between the
games
and uh also these players are really in
good shape and yes they have a few bad
moments but overall the standard has
been exceptional this has been
impressive uh comeback for sure Rook F5
Queen H2 King F1
Alice Jesus there's nothing to be done
Bishop D4 Rook takes F6 Knight takes B7
we don't want to count the ways that
white is winning uh it's it's too much
now this is the type of position
Christian if you said to me it was plus
six I believe you there are other
positions where you say the positions
plus six and I I only felt I was
slightly better double that completely
overwhelming plus 12 plus 12. yeah okay
it's over I mean yeah maybe you have to
go something like Knight G8 allow me
Bishop to D4 sacrifice every single
piece you have on sacrifice like Bishop
E5 I take only five you take back with
the queen and you pray that you're not
gonna get checked maybe in the next
couple of moves but I just like the word
sacrifice
yes flesh wound
oh boy okay so uh I guess we're just
gonna see the handshake we're waiting
for the handshake here as
Alice just simply doesn't have a move no
there's no moves I mean maybe you can
try to go back to D6 but I can take home
B7 if I want and look at that a little
smile on Nazi's face is it just me or is
there a little bit there's a huge smile
she knows she's got it in the bag right
and it's like a good movie right so you
can sit back and enjoy her position play
out
truly I mean it's a bad sign when you
want you have to go back to D6 and I
think we were looking at Queen D6
instead of Queen E5 and you got your
Rook to have fun in the game at Tempo
yeah which is like oh dear oh dear the
match continues right as you continue
the bash continues and uh well if it
does go
if it does continue then we're going to
see tie breaks where the players will be
playing two more games at the time
control of 10 minutes plus five second
increment per move
now that's a I mean
uh Alice
the much younger participant
I always thought of Junior players as
great Blitz players like I thought that
I was a much better Blitz player than a
tournament player like I may have had a
tournament rating but I thought I was
like a strong a player in Blitz
so oftentimes Junior players their Blitz
ratings they're underrated in Blitz is
that the case with Alice do we do we
feel that she's a Blitzer well we
haven't really seen too much of him and
we saw her lose in the in the tie breaks
yesterday Arena that wasn't in the blitz
that was in the Rapids
not to my eyes I think she's a very good
classical player in fact yeah so she's
worked on that side of her game she
likes to think she likes to take her
time and choose her plans when she gets
out of the opening
I think it helps her balance her
attributes very very well if she has
longer time controls exactly she did
play a move Knight takes G4 okay I mean
somewhat creative at least Knight takes
G4 H takes G4 I'm very happy to set up
Bishop D4 check you can trade but you
you still have
got to defend this this killer threat I
also wonder whether you could throw in
please
um Bishop D4 immediately yeah
immediately immediately I've never
had someone to say that but I like it
yes
yes okay just just keep it simple yeah
keep it simple or take the piece the
free piece there is no compensation that
is a free piece of things F5 and you can
just see from the way that yeah the body
language
for sure yeah
no question of time that did not look
like The Confident recapture of somebody
who's really got this game under control
uh Rook takes H well just because Naji
is thinking Queen takes F5 why not
well because
but at the same time GTX F5 you also
keep Queen takes H6 on the board exactly
and he also closed the f file so I went
and and you're kind of keeping a a
potentially a watchful eye for a
Checkmate I think G takes F5 plays
itself yeah
but just the fact that
that uh the the that she's thinking
could suggests to me that she's uh it
certainly looks like oh Alice are not
the only ones headed to tie breaks
because hey take a look at this and uh
the players on our rook and king against
the King and King uh
back to back
and we're gonna see two sets of playoffs
both playing is that the rule in Chess
By the way you're playing a match
and you play three games to King versus
King is it three game repetition and a
Thai man
I've reached this position three times
in the match I'm claiming I'm claiming a
drawn match he's invented a new one I
like it yes I mean you have to go to two
weeks of feed a arbitering school to
discover if that's a part of the fide
rules uh what do you got uh because we
still have one game left okay most
likely we're going to see a resignation
very soon but we do have G takes by the
way that too compelling simple chess
right now it just feels like you either
go Queen to D6 allow me to exchange the
Queens if I want to maybe I go F6 maybe
I exchange the Queens then I take on B7
that's two pieces that's resignation yep
I can go F6 that's resignation but
whatever she's reached and she's played
Queen sure Queen H4 okay
you're stopping Bishop D4 I understand
that but what about your idea with 96
yeah that's about just the only thing it
does right uh
so it threatens Rook G8 I don't know
Bishop D4 threatens that's it
I'm sorry
no there's no thread okay yeah
well pointed out yeah okay I you I'm a
bit
I kind of just like tickle you Bishop F2
so I can drop the Rook on the position
Bishop F2 like for instance could you
just kind of put it in the bank and go
Knight takes Bishop yes of course two
pieces off true and next turn go Queen
takes H6 as well yeah I was just
thinking if I had this position in a
Blitz game I'm playing Bishop F2 and the
classical game I may be playing 19 B7
but Bishop F2 just you know keeping the
attack look at that Queen takes H6
and Bishop takes H6 and
again
you've got you know Rook check and
rookie seven
let's take another part
Bishop takes C6 why not
yeah
boy that's
that that's just simply overwhelming
isn't it you want to go F6 you can do
that that's one right
yeah
um I would have played Knight takes B7
waiting for the provocation before
playing Queen takes H6 but let's face it
extra piece Chuck overwhelming oh
Bishop retreats to E3
just reminding uh
black that the bishop on C8 is in a pin
I sort of like what Nazi is doing
because she could easily just Blitz out
a few moves and force resignation
but she's letting her opponents suffer
right now and sometimes this is the
worst feeling because you know they're
completely positive you're just like
okay makes a move so that I can reside
right and your opponent just stops and
thinks and takes her time enjoys the
moment and you obviously just want to
get out of there right go back to your
room get ready for the next set of
matches your opponent just doesn't let
you do that
Bishop E3 best move in the position
Bishop E3 just defending the Knight oh
look at this how devilish she's setting
up a cheapo Bishop A6 check that's okay
and that was that's it uh Alice said
look I needed a way to get out of here
let me play My One Last Cheapo uh
imagine didn't fall for it and we have
two tied matches yes we do we do and uh
let's have a look at the results in the
playoff sorry in the match between Devon
aronian and Wesley so it was tied and
that means that they are playoff bound
and the same situation in the match
between Naji paikitsi and Alice Lee both
players very impressive games with white
pieces and again off to the playoffs but
they got there in very different ways
two drawn games tough drawn games Wesley
had the upper hand the first but in
these with the ladies two brutal
victories I mean really kind of
one-sided I want to say and we're going
to be doing the playoffs
there's a there's a a gap between when
they play
so what are we going to do during this
Gap we we ask the players right we did
we asked the players what do they think
of this format
[Music]
the American Cup is played under a
unique and exciting double elimination
format what is fun about it in Europe
actually this is my first time here I
changed my Federation like couple of
months ago so this is a like new thing
to me and I'm looking forward to it this
is a very interesting event it's kind of
different event I would say the format
is different and also even the time
control I do really like the format it's
a lot of fun and I think the players
also enjoy that it has different time
controls it's not just classical chess
oh I like this tournament knockout
system I think it's like very first
Spectators It's a Wonderful system it's
more interesting than around robin
tournament every game is very important
and for spectators I think it's it's
it's more interesting format for us also
I like something different I'm quite
excited to play in the American Cup I've
never played in this type of tournament
before where we have mix of classical
and Rapid how I like it I guess that
depends on how I do
so I will tell you that after the
tournament yeah so I think certainly the
world has changed a lot in terms of
Chess over the last couple of years a
lot of people in terms of the fans they
want to see quicker chess tournaments
that don't go as long as they have
traditionally so when you have a match
format I think this is a little bit of a
template similar to the feeder World Cup
which is an event that's held similarly
where you have two game matches you have
Knockouts and you have an ultimate
winner and I think that when you have a
format like this where you do have a
winner at the end of the day and even if
it's after a couple of days of play
nonetheless you have someone winning
when they're playing head to head that's
certainly more favorable and I think the
fans like that so I'm pretty optimistic
about the format I think it should be a
great show for everyone I really enjoy
formats like this where you mix
classical just rapid chest and even if
it gets their Blitz chest because it's
like three kind of different skill sets
that a player has to have well I'm a
huge proponent of knockout style
tournaments in general I think that's
absolutely the best way to run any
individual sport uh just included and so
I'm delighted to be playing this
knockout event uh my big dream would be
four game classical matches and knockout
because this one does tilt quite a bit
towards Rapid and then once you've lost
you start playing rapid very quickly for
that but uh yeah I'm a huge proponent of
knockout events and I'm very very happy
to see that you know the the best chess
club in the world is hosting knockout
events now you know now the second year
in a row and I hope it continues to be a
tradition yeah well this is my second
time playing in it and I think last year
I was pretty confused about the format
uh now I have a better idea of what it's
about
um and I enjoyed it last year yeah it's
a fun format double elimination the nice
thing is that there's a second chance so
if someone has a moment of of weakness
or an accident that happens in one of
their games there's still a second
chance like a chance of redemption let's
say it's even stronger than last year
last year he covered in Play and now
he's joining and so all the best chess
players in the United States are playing
it's a genuine super tournament I really
enjoyed playing in this tournament last
year it was a lot of fun I like the
double elimination at the World Cup
which is a single elimination and it's
kind of said he lives early on and then
you have to live and go home so I like
the fact that everyone still gets a
second chance I really like the format I
think it's a it's very interesting
format that you have a chance to come
back to the tournament uh after being
knocked out and the field is extremely
strong I'm happy that Hikaru is playing
this year it's always nice to see him
for me this is a kind of a special
tournament uh
for the first time I'm
playing tournament and staying in my
house you know in St Louis
this is something that I really missed
because I think last time I stayed in my
house and played and played the
classical tournament I was 19. so
special kill well I kind of like the
global elimination format it's been
it's become very popular lately online
also I just finished the tournament
Berlin also's double elimination so I
like the idea that it has two lives that
each player gets two lives
um then you get another chance and I
also like the match format I'm very
excited about this format that's my
favorite thing about American Cup
because I like that we play a match this
bracket and double elimination uh format
it's it's very exciting for us players
because we get to play one player twice
and really kind of measure our strength
with that one player and if it doesn't
work out we still have like uh you know
recovery that we can still get back to
the tournament compared to other
tournaments where you always play uh you
know one person just like with one color
and it takes forever here if you are in
good shape like just go go no one is
stopping you and if you are not then the
tournament is over so I think it's nice
for no matter what your uh current shade
this is the only tournament I've ever
played in with this format and I really
like it because
um I think that classical chess is
definitely like a great part of like
determining
um the result of matches based on
playing instruments but rapid chest is
like super exciting to watch for General
audience it's also very strong it's kind
of like the US Championship but with the
strongest possible players
and personally for me it's uh it's kind
of like the start of the season because
I took a long break from playing
classical chess so my last tournament
was the U.S Championship which was back
in October like ages ago it feels like
so this is uh the first time that I'll
be playing classical which is nice and
I'm really looking forward to it I was
looking forward for this tournament to
be honest I love it doublelon mentioned
a lot of like exciting moments a lot of
fun to have around and I I just like
this tournament in general it's just
like two chances and different formats
and four months in one tournament which
is great so this is one of my favorite
tournaments actually
[Music]
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
meet me at the beauty the beauty in
Forest Park the muni's premier season
bursting with comedy's romance and Magic
Begins June 12th with the muni premiere
of beautiful the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
sister
[Music]
Forest Park
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in-store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
this gives us a chance to present
another concert from the World Chess
Hall of Fame music director Brian Owens
performs we were back with final
coverage of the American Cup in the
meantime enjoy this special presentation
from the World Chess Hall of Fame
foreign
[Music]
good evening everybody how you doing
[Applause]
we want to welcome everybody to the
World Chess Hall of Fame music series
this is our first show of the 2023
season yes
my name is Brian Owens and I am the
music director one of the music
directors and artists in Residence here
and I'm so excited to see you tonight on
behalf of Rex and Jeannie sinkfield
thank you so much sir
all of our staff our amazing staff here
we want to say thank you for being here
you make this possible and tonight I get
the privilege of kicking off the series
um
so we're gonna be doing things that are
related to chess and things that are
related to 1972 the year that probably
changed chess as we know it in the world
when Bobby Fischer beat Boris basket
yes so
um I'm not going to talk a lot tonight
we're going to play a couple tunes right
now from 1972.
you may know this one
oh the band is Rob Woody on drums
I was turned that way I figured I may as
well introduce him
Logan Miller on guitar
and on piano and Moog Bass
adamantis
one of the few people who could actually
do this what he's about to hit what
you're about to hear
laughs
are you ready man let's go
all right
[Music]
friends
trying to tell me
[Music]
all you wanna do is use me
my answer
what all that I use mixed up
[Music]
and my big brother
yeah but when I talk was through
[Music]
my shoes
just keep on using me
till you use
fearsville
hey you know sometimes sometimes
is true you really do abuse me
get me among your high class
ES
[Music]
feel this good fingers
keep on using me
[Music]
language
talking about you using people
[Music]
you do
talking about you using people
but you know ain't no better way of
using me cause I show him using you to
do the thing you do
head to the thing you do
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
you know
but you know I kind of did it like that
the last time
I sang it
you know
Adam
how else
could we could we could we do this all
[Music]
right
so in love with you
whatever you want to do
it's all right with me
[Music]
make me feel so brand new
I want to spend my life
with you
[Music]
I said
yes
we've been together
[Music]
it's what I need
please
[Music]
foreign
I'm loving your weather
times
[Music]
why some people break up
while they turn around and make
I just can't
honey
[Music]
I know that you'll never do that to me
Stay Together
[Music]
thank you
okay
where the time took
[Music]
me
and sad
thank you
where the times
[Music]
yeah man
I like that version I like that version
that's fun
all right
um
time is flying it's about time to bring
up someone other than myself
ladies and gentlemen
y'all
this is a bad woman
you know I have a a soft spot in my
heart for soulful singers
and uh
she's right in there
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome
to the world chest Hall of Fame stage
the lovely the incomparable the Soulful
miss Emily Wallace
[Music]
thank you
so we're gonna do a little 1972 stuff
for you and then we go
we're gonna really Soul it out
a little bit
um figure out the stool first yeah yeah
yeah
um
how many of you were born in 1972 I'm
just playing you don't have to register
but you remember this music well you you
may have uh you may have you know been
riding along in 1972 in the car you know
some of you probably had kids by then
um
retired and I was just playing I was
just playing split
and and you turn on the radio station
the pop station and you heard something
like
like yeah or your a track
in your car
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
hey
it's gonna be a bright life
[Applause]
[Music]
the sunshiny day
look all around
there's nothing but blue sketch
look straight ahead
[Music]
please
I can see
[Music]
it my way
[Applause]
[Music]
it's gonna be a prize
Emily Wallace y'all
I'm so happy to be here
y'all ain't even ready for what y'all
ain't ready for this
oh yeah we got let's go down to Memphis
one
two three
good questions
[Music]
I remember it now
I don't wanna lose this good thing
that I got cause if I do
I would surely
surely loses
[Music]
lightning
the way you love me is
[Music]
[Applause]
superstitious
[Music]
baby
thank you
ain't no secret
that a woman
feels my loving cup cause she sees
to it
that I could end up I just wonder
from your baby
[Music]
think I'm better
than nothing
[Music]
I think
hey hey
[Music]
[Applause]
another one from the album by Otis
Redding and Carla Thomas entitled king
and queen which is why we do
this was made famous first by
the most famous vibrato in human history
Mr Aaron Neville
it says something like this
if you want
something to play with
go and find yourself a tour
cause baby my time is too expensive
and I'm not a little boy
[Music]
Brian
with you I'll see you
[Music]
don't mess with my heart
it makes me feel weird
but if you want me
to love you
honey you know I'm real
[Music]
you know I we
tell it like it
don't be ashamed
just let your conscience be your guide
[Music]
yo
Foolish Pride
[Music]
thank you
know that life
life is too short
to have sorrow
maybe he
[Music]
gone tomorrow
so you might as well
do what you want
[Music]
she'll go on indeed Kitty
don't be ashamed
to let your conscience be your guide
[Music]
it is
deep down inside
[Music]
don't be ashamed
that your conscience
[Music]
till the night
oh don't get so proud
[Music]
[Applause]
gonna do a little Sam cook for you right
now
okay
let me try it again we're gonna do a
little Sam cook for you right now thank
you thank you we got some saying okay
okay thank you Sam Cook people thank you
you ready man
[Music]
thank you
shh
if you ever
change your mind
[Music]
about leaving
me behind
just
sing it to me
bring yours sweetener
bring it on home to me
again
yeah yeah
if you give me jewelry
have somebody too
and everything
that you do I'm sure
[Music]
thank you
you know I try
[Music]
to treat you right
but honey you stay down
late at night
[Music]
bring your sweet loving
bring it home
[Music]
say it again
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
let me hear you say yeah
yeah
say it
[Music]
oh yeah
oh and bring it to me
bring yours sweet loving and bring it on
home to me
yeah one more time let me hear y'all say
yeah
Harmony
[Music]
come on say yeah
yeah
bring it to me just bringing I don't
Sweet Love Me
bring it on home to me
[Music]
saying yeah yeah say yeah
bring it to me
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks
[Music]
y'all doing all right
you sure
[Music]
I know a place
ain't no smiling faces
[Music]
you ain't nobody crying
ha
[Music]
unted
ain't no smiling faces
[Music]
it goes
one more time
[Music]
I'll take you there
I'll take you there we're going away
[Music]
you know I'm Gonna Fly Away
going to oh God
[Music]
I'm going to
home
[Music]
and when I go you know that I have
I'll take you there
[Music]
come on
you don't help me
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
please
slowly out in space
[Music]
talking
skills
[Music]
ain't the kind of place
to raise your keys
[Music]
and there's no one there to raise them
even if you do
[Music]
and I'll miss science I just don't
understand
it's just my top five days a week
[Music]
a rocket man
[Applause]
and uh
me
rocking things
[Music]
[Applause]
please
[Music]
[Applause]
gonna be a long long time
and I think it's gonna be
a long time
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and Gentlemen Just we got a
couple more for you but again Rob Woody
on drums
[Applause]
Logan Miller on guitar
add on Menace on everything plus the
kitchen sink
Emily Wallace
and I'm Brian Owens
a lot of stuff going on in the world
always
[Music]
um
1972 I joke but it was it was a long
time ago
and we still dealing with some of the
same stuff
humans will be human
human which means love Must Be Love
Bill Withers wrote this song
when record labels thought songs like
this couldn't sell
nobody wanted to hear songs like this
and it ended up being a hit
and all he was doing was expressing
the Deep need that we all have to have
somebody say
song
sometimes
[Music]
Lean on Me
When You're Not Strong
I'll be your friend
I'll help you carry on
[Music]
it won't be long
till I'm gonna be
somebody to
lean on
please swallow your pie
if I have things
you need to fall
for no one can be
fill those of your needs
[Music]
somebody to leave
should I just might have a problem
[Music]
to me
if
there is a love
you
cannot make
that you can't
carry you don't know
[Music]
and you know I'll share your love
if you just
call me insane you're just caught on me
brother I wanna go there with you did a
hand we all need somebody to
leave
[Music]
somebody to
lean on to Lean on Me
[Music]
I'll be afraid
I'll help you
carry on
you won't be long till I'm gonna need
somebody to me call me well just call
call me if you need a friend call me
[Music]
call me when you need a friend just cold
need a help in hand
I need someone to love you
[Music]
foreign
start you know we saw trades bit uh
sorry blows been traded in the matchup
between Naji paikitsa and Alice Lee and
in the open section let's have a look at
how they got a lot along and we saw it
was two drawers but two very eventful
drawers yes they were Wesley so was
pushing LaVon aronian in that first game
and this means that in the ladies
section this is where the blows being
traded as Naji lost the first game very
decisively and Alice yes lost the second
game very decisively as well so we're
gonna see a very exciting playoff and
this is what they are fighting for they
are fighting for a spot in the Grand
Final where they will go up to the
Champions bracket and meet Irina Crush
as waiting in the wings tomorrow and uh
there we can see well Arena's path to
the top was very smooth and it knitted
her a 5 000 Champions bracket bonus and
in the open section
elimination bracket is all between
Wesley so and the Von oronian who has
kind of been working up the standings
like a submarine and they will face none
other than Hikaru Nakamura the number
one seed yes the headline act and he
picks up a spot in the Grand Final and
also Nets a ten thousand dollar bonus
as we get ready for this competition
the players will be speeding up the
tempo of the game as well we just saw
the 25 minute games now we're going to
be seeing ten plus five seconds ten plus
five sorry yes sometimes they get
confused by these sad time controls and
well they'll play black and white yes
this is not going to be the Armageddon
game so uh we're all
anxiously well waiting I know but one
cool thing about this set of matches is
that they switch colors yes so Wesley
started with white pieces in their first
encounter the 25 plus 10 right now when
we switch to 10 plus 5 is going to be
Levon and a Nazi respectively who will
start with the white pieces and we've
seen how important those white pieces
were especially in the ladies section
well I want to say Alice's games with
black are concerning shaky because Arena
Crush really had it her way uh in the
game that she was White when she played
Alice yesterday in today's game Naji
looked really real with the way she
played the white pieces so something
about these Nimble nimso Indian Queens
Gambit positions are not working very
well for Alice at the moment
and of course uh we've got a blitz
tournament coming up on Sunday the fun
just keeps on coming on Sunday there'll
be Blitz event nine rounds no draw
offers it's a very fast time control of
three minutes plus two seconds and it
will include roughly 40 players
including those from local universities
and eliminated American Club
participants so it's gonna be super
strong including our very own
yeah varg throwing his hat into the ring
uh he's actually been training with a
lot of the St Louis University uh team
is coaching as as a trainer so you know
he's going to have to show these
youngsters how the pieces move but we'll
look forward to that
um what is going to separate Wesley and
uh Lavon from one another uh Christian
did you pick up anything in those first
two games that uh yeah Wesley's whites
white pieces are very very strong so
we're going to have to wait and see for
the second match how Wesley is going to
uh well whether he will be able to get
an advantage out of the opening just
like he was able to do so against Hikaru
Nakamura and against leonoronia in their
first match so the first one that's
going to have to change something when
Wesley is going to be with the white
pieces is going to be Levon because I
have to say Wesley got a very very good
position out of the opening this is what
I'm looking at the white pieces for
Wesley so Levon I mean look Wesley's
Petrov every by the way Everybody Plays
the Petrov nowadays it seems like at a
little level you see linear you've had
Fabiano who was playing the Petrov now
of course nepo but now we have even
Wesley Wesley never played the Bedrock
before at least not to my knowledge I
only remember him as a knight CC
Explorer and things of that nature but
right now this is what he's doing he's
playing the petroff and he's very solid
he knows what he's doing he showed it in
their second match Levon wasn't able to
get any opening advantage and he will
have to come up with something new
right and uh for you Jovi and the ladies
how do you separate the two and how do
you see the match unfolding
I think it's all going to
depend on how they do with the white
pieces because we see energy she's very
impressive though she knows she chooses
her her openings carefully for Alice
Alice as well has to react to those
surprises I have to say I did see Alice
preparing on the streets of Saint Louis
with her laptop and with a telephone
obviously a hotline to the coach I love
it so she's got her laptop her coach on
the line and everything to play for
she's trying to make the finals for the
second year in a row I mean uh it's it's
strange this event how Arena crash
uh relegated Alice to the elimination
bracket Alice came right back but then
lost the matches we know arena is the
defending Champion looking to do the
same and Nashi stands to Norway yep she
said it does and the handshake
um
D4 and if I remember correctly it was
Alice Lee last year that eliminated is
that correct
by the way we I don't think Naji played
she did not play she played in the U.S
championships
she definitely eliminated her in this
competition yeah in the classical
encounter
and now Naja is trying to take revenge
right that match by the way this is
usually similar to what uh levonne and
Wesley played I was about to say C takes
D5 sure looks like a similar setup right
Bishop B7 by the way Bishop on E2 why
Bishop E2 I'm not a big fan of that move
me either because in general you want to
play E4 that's that's how you get out
with the white pieces and get the
advantage is only two then I mean I will
be able to take on e4 and then
immediately open up the long diagonal
with C5 right the only reason I can
imagine that the bishop shouldn't be on
D3 is you go castles and Rook D1 very
very quickly so that you can play E4
with the bishop on E2
well I don't know uh
it looks a little timid let's put it
that way b2b3
Bishop B2 on White's agenda castles
bring the Rooks to the center Bishop D6
Queen E7 Castle
solid solid stuff I have to say though I
mean yes it looks timid but I have seen
it recommended yes and uh courses I know
Sam shankland himself was advocating for
a system very similar to this with the
bishop on each with a bishop on E2 with
the idea that
yeah you could move the Knight back to
D2 at certain stages I mean it's it's a
complicated line sure but uh also a lot
of play for both sides a lot of games in
this uh variation very topical line and
also very topical is the Berlin so for
the moment Wesley put uh the
Russian defense the Petrov defense on
hold played the Berlin takes takes takes
and
going straight into the Berlin ending 95
Knight
D4 so how exactly can one beat Wesley
when he's playing the petroff and the
Berlin these are the two most difficult
openings
to bit with the white pieces when you
start with one E4 is just
brutal yeah
help me out here on this one Christian
Knight G5 Knight D4 these two
moves they look to my eyes off the
beaten path for who
for for white right for white yes I
think he missed this move Knight to D4
isn't this just winning a pawn well it
sure looks that way to me to my eyes as
well Bishop G5
like gifting the pawn uh not that
there's anything wrong with the pond
gift I I like that but also Bishop E7
but you usually get something in return
for the pawn gift you're not getting
anything in this situation I don't I'm
not sure that's true I kind of Yasser
come on I I'm kind of thinking that this
Pawn is pretty isolated this is
absolutely shocking to me that you
haven't taken that pawn on the scene
well I I I I want that one but I want
that one too this is the biggest shock
of this podcast
uh and this is uh I don't know if you
play Rook C2 shall we just just have a
quick look with me for a second here I'm
gonna play Rook Here pawn here and I'm
Gonna Last so the E5 Pawn yes he's
taking it
No One Believes you I mean I understand
you're trying to cover Your Tracks but
no one believes you you're gonna take
that part instantaneously okay well he
sure did and uh Wesley said look upon my
word uh the night by the way will have a
gorgeous Square on the I mean that's an
outpost that you are not kicking me out
of uh
was this a this is a blender it is it's
it's a it's not a pawn sacrifice let's
just put it this way it's important it's
a pawn blunder right now but the
shocking part is Lavon has been
preparing the Berlin himself right I
mean he's been playing and very
successfully as black and then he gets
the position as white knee blunders upon
you know how difficult the Berlin and
how confusing the Berlin is right right
you can play with the black pieces with
the King on E8 with the King on C8 the
bishop on D7 the bishop only six there
are so many iterations at the Berlin you
can easily get lost and this is exactly
what seems to have happened with Levon
in this case
a miracle will save him because this is
just a pawn up and it is such a healthy
Pawn right it is a very beautiful
majority on the queen side once you
start that roll you put the Knight on D6
B6 C5 C4 is going to be suffocating for
white species is there any hope you know
I'm thinking you know yes
he's a pawn down Whoopsie Daisy you made
a blunder
the game continues right you can go F4
F5 try to
get some activity you can try you can
definitely try Okay so he's put his
Knight on e4 which was also something
that I thought about but then I thought
that black or simply gave Bishop E7
any takers I really don't understand
what's what's wrong with you guys take
the point take the pot
is there any takers for Knight takes A2
I I'll take it yes thank you very much
that that's two very good pawns right
that's two pawns yes yeah and if you
move your Bishop in order to play Knight
G5 you're not you're not scaring anybody
that is two pawns and I'm a hungry man
thank you thank you that's that's the
biggest compliment since the show began
all right we're greedy for pawns and
Knight takes A2 certainly has my
attention H7 H6 Knight D5 pretty sure
Wesley's thinking
about it too he's taking it okay I
thought he was shouldn't grab right but
but just for fun I mean come on uh
really where's the compensation that's a
good question where is the guy full come
on let's go let's go okay so I just want
to stop any future Knight G5 ideas
Bishop h four let's go
Bishop E7
that was a big huff and a puff it was a
big half and a puff okay I can't
obviously swap that off so Bishop
where are you back back to after the
alien okay
and your whole F4 F5 is suddenly in
tatters all right is he taking it or not
nice okay I have an idea Knight C5 okay
trade them off yeah yeah more trades
more yes yes yes F5 right there you go
smells like trees and that's it it's the
little big trees that count that's
either way it's four versus one on the
queen side I'm glad I got some good news
I've got some bad news you got your F5
but yeah well Knight takes A2 he doesn't
have that much time does he I mean uh
seven minutes for both players 7 minutes
and 40 seconds for Lavon he's trying to
speed things up trying to put some
pressure on the clock Wesley seven
minutes thinking about munching on that
opponent he does and he convinced
himself the more he looked at it he said
you know what you don't even have the
usual the usual compensations that uh
you might think you have fr5 G4 G5 G4 F5
it's not there no it's not there it's
just not am I the only one who has like
a running commentary going on when they
play chess like you put on voices and
you kind of you kind of try to make it
into like some kind of Dramatics drama
thing like for me if I take that phone
I'll put on like this British voices
I'll have that
I'll have that thank you very much you
have this dialogue with my pieces when I
met played like I just you know say to
them like okay you you you bring it home
you know like that that I'm coordinating
you you know you're you're the chosen
one you know like Victory is assured uh
but as a commentator no I I I'm so
respectful of yourself and Christian
that I don't even think are going
if you believe
anything
um okay so what is Lavon going to do
come on come on uh
people give come up with something
there's there's nothing I mean he's not
coming up with anything either I think
he just bluffed he bluffed Wesley
okay I mean Jovi you were looking
reaching for the F Pawn but I think this
is a Prelude
F5 and he's done it and he said okay
what else am I supposed to do the only
thing I have is my majority is on the
king side and here we were thinking just
simply Knight D5 yeah F5 something like
King F7 and you or you know what I
really do like the move H6 I I really
like stopping any you know finagles with
Knight G5 maybe even Bishop E7
maybe even Bishop E7
but by the way I was looking
yeah you were trying to get Knight wow
yeah no 95 F5 Bishop E7 sure
this is
that's such a useful
oh my gosh yeah
it all is very logical isn't it right
one thing I can tell you I think we're
going to see a modern next game
well that's it that's Wesley opens with
E4
okay well no you open up with D4 we'll
still see the kind of a modern uh the
enchetto some kinds of Kings Indian
usually players whenever you go D4 G6
players with the white pieces play E4
that's true yeah because it's considered
to be such a good opening for white
objectively
by the way I mean you you've played F4
and I understand you know you've got to
get your majority going but just you
know after you've played F5 King D7 you
kind of come to a stop once again
because you don't
you've played F5 but you don't really
want to capture on E6 and if you bypass
well it's sort of like you have
a protected past Pawn on F6 which is
actually pretty firmly blocked blockaded
for the time being so I don't know I I
just don't see what uh what
all of this demonstration is going to
bring sorry just to finish that point
that I was making F6 here here now is
the perfect time to get in the bishop E7
move
wow Bishop takes E7 King takes E7 a
dream come true for Berlin shall we see
what's going on in the Alice League yes
yes
that one is heating up as well
by the way she missed a golden
opportunity uh Naji pakiza that is by
the way she got a tremendous position
once again did she yes Nazi with that
five Queen T2 Rook over Bishop D3 gift
made upon
Queen F7 what what oh Knight G5 Queen
H5 H3 setting up this threat H6
Rook D1 but instead of Rook 2 a to a to
D1 she had this golden opportunity of
opening up the a2ga diagonal with the
move C5 absolutely now Rook takes E6
this is the uh this is crushing this is
absolutely if you move the bishop I
can't even take on H6 if I want
absolutely once I open up that diagonal
you're you're busting by the way this is
something that you always look at
tactically the reason why you look at C4
C5 from the Tactical point of view
because black so self-evidently wants to
play C6 C5 herself you could shut her
down a big and golden missed opportunity
for sure her position is still beautiful
though
[Music]
also in a nice way Bishop C4 that's
or maybe she went to fa to be eight
really to B8 wait a minute living the
long diagonal open like this I know that
does look uh that's dangerous look I
guess she's banking on playing Knight F6
and Knight D5 and if a knight does
appear on E5 she'll Trade It Off faster
than you can say very good point
um
wow I'm just looking at this awful awful
Bishop I understand what you're saying
about the Knight coming to D5 and even
though it's not my very first choice
something as crude as
this I mean visually you can see that
white is the one enjoying all the space
right and these Bishops are pretty
locked in
is not my first choice either as whites
I think I would probably be trying to
build the positions a little bit like
you've highlighted okay also want to
double on the e-line yes but uh
definitely I think Alice has to not
obsess so much about them
was played
one of the things that I can say about
this type of position for black is don't
obsess about this bad Bishop on B7 it's
bad accept it and you just get on and
you just go well you know I will simply
react to whatever white does and as long
as you're surviving on a move by move
basis then
you can defend
I know it's ugly this is this is super
ugly I don't think I would have taken on
C5 I'll be honest with you because it
opens up another line of attack for the
white Rooks
yeah I mean if we could magically play
the illegal move we're up to D1 to D6
that would be uh game set and match I'm
just wondering how big a threat is the
move Knight takes C5
uh Queen before asked the question
directly Knight takes C5 you're
obviously
it's a bit of a strange move to allow
1965 right yeah I think somehow I wanted
to do it where where my Rook was coming
to D6 I
well she took it yeah I think where I
was heading was something more along the
lines of Bishop C2 Knight takes Rook to
D6 something like this don't even think
of opening up my diagonal she has played
instead Queen before Knight takes C5
yeah I'm not very convinced about uh the
sequence of moves the ship C2 I I mean
again I I am seeing or visualizing The
Rook dropping in on D6 and thinking okay
I have massively good what if I put the
Rook on D5
I think that's a cover everything
necessary and very does it
no but it feels like Alice is taking
over doesn't it
well wait a minute Bishop to D4
she's done Bishop to D4 you can just and
what are the clocks between the two okay
so uh
Alice has uh just
four and a half minutes was Nazi has uh
three and a half minutes
that's a spicy move it certainly is it
invites Queen B6
let's go for it Queen Z6 kind of like uh
shouldering up to the the bishop on B7
it doesn't invites Bishop takes C5 right
I like this move I'm just
no Bishop plays Five I take I think
that's within rook and queen B6 Naji
playing
staying ahead on the clock I'm sorry
yeah he's she's four and a half minutes
and uh Naji is three minutes
um ticking down less
and yeah
only has 30 minutes 30 seconds sorry 30
minutes 30 seconds yes and he is broke
down but okay he's in for a penny in for
a pound this was the exchange sacrifice
I wasn't even sure I wanted to take it I
wanted to play King D7 and Levon saying
no I I
I'm going to try to go
Hog Wild with something like Knight F6
Rook takes C7 how do you do I don't what
if I go night back 93 makes sense and
then they could just go all in yes okay
oh yeah Knight F6 I was going to have
taken and go Knight D6 check that was my
My Hope was to go Knight D6 and I get to
connect to pass bonds I think yeah yeah
and now you can go g Bishop B7
no Bishop ec7
king of Faith yeah
yeah you are a rook Downer
don't bother me with the details
I'm just telling you how you say you're
going to win this game you want to look
at two points now now you're just a
rooftop
uh yeah okay Rook F7 on the board and
Wesley plenty of time against 30 seconds
we think that uh
is there any way for Wesley to go wrong
so for instance so he doesn't go Knight
E3 you know tries to go I'm sure there
are eights or something yeah I'm sure
there are a hundred like this is one way
where suddenly you know you've got these
two past bonds that
are terrified if you go G5 I mean how
how dangerous is it oh you even have G5
that
that's a setback
it is but oh dear uh sorry uh yeah uh it
seems like I did play Rook season Wesley
really loves his pawns wow this is what
I was wondering right so if you just
take some negative decision Bishop F6
don't take on F6 don't touch that Bishop
that's one thing you shouldn't do and
that's how you go wrong
take the bishop and then hear at last we
do see a checkmate
so he didn't take the bishop of oops
excuse me that was my dad and I will
just refresh my board it will only take
me a second Rook C8 Rook G8
H5 I mean talk about going all in all
and all in
there you go I would take that right
yeah why not I hate you no he brings his
Knight back to the game okay so take oh
then you take with a check
five seconds and G6 oof
okay now you can just bring it back to
509 D5
it's a beautiful protected Square Bishop
E7 is next and uh
Bishop E7 maybe bishop takes E7 and
Knight F6 check that's like all right F6
I take and I take on G6 with Chuck yeah
maybe Knight D6
maybe Knight T6 but even then I just
I'll give you the Rook I'll take that
I'll take on G6 you go D7 I go King d8
what about if you're going okay he's
he's asked the same question I asked
seconds seven five four he's taking
place and you gotta go Knight D6 check
or Knight F6 no Knight F6 you told me
the G6 Pawn is hanging with check there
he goes Knight D6 check take on G6 and
now you said you're just gonna give me
The Rook I'll give you the Rook yes so
you're gonna move the Knight by
capturing okay for that
H4 instantly
what is
sacrificing everything I'll play H5 I
would go Rook d8 I'll sidestep the the
big threat
and Wesley with under three minutes has
all the time in the world
to me kitty even and how about nice porn
ah 95.
over there you have a draw right because
the Rick will go to East service oh my
God I have one check no no you don't
that is that is probably the most
unexpected Perpetual check you'll ever
see in your life you're rook in the
night and many pawns down and you you
took the wrong Pawn oh my goodness
so not that one Rook d8 95 there are so
many ways and guys
f8 and this looks like she's well on the
way to winning a game oh my goodness
okay as we do expect uh Wesley to win
this game let's just something went
wrong for naju and we left it ah she got
her Queen trapped
we left it after Queen B8 night before
Bishop A4
Rook A8 look at this she got her Queen
trapped
and suddenly
oh my goodness and the bishop is hanging
on A4 handshake
Alice Lee has won the first game with
the black pieces
and they'll have a very short break and
then I'll do it all over it again could
you define short break for just
we had a short break a while ago didn't
we
well they'll play as soon as this game
is finished uh-huh okay uh is
shortly after this game is finished then
they'll probably turn in probably 10 15
minutes whatever Wesley really doesn't
want to give any points
Knight F A and look at that move boy he
loves his Pawns
and Levon gives up there's nothing to do
and Levon cannot believe it yeah well I
mean you've seen those big poker pots
where guys holding absolutely nothing
seven in the deuce he just keeps going
all in and the other guy's holding a
royal flush
they bring it nothing happening that
that missed its Mark bye yeah but I mean
I have to say Lavon actually blonded
and lost two pawns and then you know he
had to kind of go all in he had to
sacrifice the whole house if he was to
try to do anything okay uh two decisive
games uh to set us up for the next game
and here we go and here we see it Levon
aronian using with the white piece
is Wesley so
and in the other Playoff between Alice
Lee and Naji pakiza it was Alice winning
with the black pieces now Naji pakiza
and levonne avonian are in a must-win
situation with the black pieces not an
easy job absolutely Christian jumped in
for a moment in this game because we
didn't see how Naji uh let me show you
because this is really cool I have yeah
I was walking through the lines and it
was really really cool at this point she
played this move Knight to E5 which at
least to my eyes it didn't seem right
because you're allowing this bishop
takes E5 the closure of the long
diagonal you don't have this idea of
playing D5 opening up this monstrous
Queen on C3 and the bishopon B2 a
battery against the King on H7 so Knight
D5 not my cup of tea nevertheless the
engine is still saying white is
completely winning they take completely
winning yes wow still completely winning
even at this point Queen to beat for a
little bit of a bad move allowing this
Knight takes C5 probably the best would
have been to actually go to C1 or Bishop
to C2 now let's take a look Knight takes
C5 Bishop to C2 Rook D5 very good move
by Alice Lee Bishop D4 A5 Queen to B6 it
still feels like white is uh almost
winning in this position the bishop B7
is still not playing an important role
all you need to do is take care of The
Rook on D5 and this is what she's trying
to do kick the Knight away play the move
Bishop to B3 attack The Rook on D5 and
force it to withdraw to d8 after which
you will be able to go Bishop C5 Rook to
D6 it's a beautiful position knightway 6
a rook to B1
really like this move Knight to B4
forget about the engines the engines are
saying that that's not the best move in
the position but I really like the
concept of it what I'm focused on right
now with only 2 minutes and 54 seconds
for Nazi is complicate and create as
much chaos as possible with the black
pieces Rook to B5 is a big one so for
example if you take uh the Knight on B4
Rook to B5 where is the queen going
Queen 287 Rook to A8 I'm hunting that
queen I'm going to be able to capture it
and that's going to create not a winning
position for black but a slightly better
situation for a black now she understood
that Nazi that is she played the move
Bishop to A4 guarding this Square B5 and
if you don't have the following move
with the black pieces and if you don't
see the following move with the black
pieces then you're just simply busted
because you move the Knight you lose the
bishop B7 you play Knight D3 you lose
the bishop on B7
sooner or later I'm probably going to go
after Knight to D3 Rook to D1 or Rook to
E3 I'm going to Target this Knight and
then I'm going to pick up the bishop on
B7 but look what she found rooked away
eight that's a very hidden move at least
to Maya as you played Knight to B4
Bishop to A4 finally I'm guarding all of
these squares uh close to my Queen Boom
Rook to A8 comes on the board Rook to A6
and there's no way to stop it so you
have to give up the queen Rook to A6
take take sure you create a beautiful
pass Pawn but C5 and right now I'm
starting to have my own attack with the
queen and finally the bishop that has
been pretty much locked the whole game
finally it has a life of its own and
after Queen to G5 things are getting
dicey for the white king queen to H5
Rook takes D5 Bishop takes D5 and here
it's all she wrote right now if instead
of the move Rook E1 to D1 uh if you go
back to that moment where where Naji
played Rook E1 to D1 by five moves ago
that one Bishop to B5 put the bishop
back on yes yes yes
sorry I have to interrupted ourselves
the play is actually started yeah that
was the short break
that was the next
unexpectedly so and oops I'm gonna need
uh some help it looks like here on this
one
and wow
and we see Naji with the black pieces
she is in a must-win situation and
we're getting to see almost a repetition
of their game in the classical encounter
a long time ago which remind I've
managed to get lost
on the site
I was going broadcast
yes
okay let's uh
and Knight to D7 all right
she really loves this D4 C5 idea she did
it once she played it twice she's trying
it once again and look she didn't get
bad positions in any of her games so no
she did not it's a fair option Knight V8
Knight to C7 try Target that pawn on B5
potentially and open up the dark Square
Bishop would be an interesting idea in
this position
okay after this move Knight D2 I really
don't like seeing the Knight coming to
C4 so if I were in black shoes I would
be most tempted by the move Knight B6
intending Queen D7 and E6 uh for Naji
and again boldly stating the obvious
black has to win to extend the match uh
further and she has played Knight B6
um and uh what I have to say in the
other game between Wesley so and Levon
Christian called it I did he said it's
going to be a modern and look position
have that position I promise you he's
another rigged
I don't have that either
no I don't have the game
so Knight B6 is all I've got we'll look
at the bird's eye view
yeah I mean uh look he expected it I'm
sure Wesley expected it
and by the way it did start with D4 G6
so not E4 D4 G6 and then E4
black on navon well he has to do one
thing and that is put as much pressure
on Wesley's clock as possible that's
what he's doing nine minutes and 57
seconds hasn't thought for a very long
time and 8 minutes 30 seconds and
dropping for Wesley try and figure out
his own setup in the position
with the move Knight B1 to D2
one of the things I like for white is
always putting this Knight on the G3
Square sorry yeah I was actually going
to say the same thing The Last Knight
was headed to G3 and it had
the Magnus Carlson
if you play this kind of hip against
this hippo formation the Knight on G3
and you cannot go wrong right your king
is going to be really really super safe
Bishop on C4 is kind of doing a pretty
decent job at uh uh tickles the pawn on
uh A6 making sure that the Rook more or
less stays there and uh well this move
Knight
um to uh F6 it encourages E5 if you play
it immediately after d-e-d-e it might be
a little bit awkward defending this Pawn
on E5 so the Prelude to E5 is the move
H3 which was played pretty quickly by
Wesley
and now black has a problem castles
encourages E5
bearing in my in the tournament
situation
that you have to win the black yes yeah
I mean you kind of feel like almost
obliged to be as provocative as you can
and did you see them yeah we saw the
move D5 from Lavon okay that kind of
makes White's task a little bit easier
after takes takes uh
94. Bishop G5 is coming Bishop G5 these
moves are
what what did you call them happy movies
easy to play you know and I think
as long as you don't overthink things
you know those are the very natural C3
reinforce the center keep everything
blocked
um
do we have to take or can we go back to
D3 also possible
Bishop to D3 yeah just to keep the
tension in the position I
I don't have to do it but it just feels
more natural
takes takes something oh you want to
exchange I'm happy well yeah again it's
just the uh the the match situations so
favorable what about this kind of
positions so you get this and then you
if I were black I'll go C5 exactly well
you after okay night night takes night
takes no no for what okay white has a
spare move yeah I was uh yeah yeah it's
getting ahead but I like what you said
C3 this is what I would what I meant
about uh the bishop and queen battery
kind of it's annoying that this Pawn on
A6 uh is constantly under threat this is
the current situation personally takes
takes Knight E4 that look looks and
feels the most natural
to me I would say White's better maybe
half upon better but
okay certainly Lavon has a position he
can play Knight to E4 yeah trying take
advantage of the fact that you have some
weak dark squares potentially after a
castle Bishop G5 most especially part
Bishop G5 again it's not the tempo that
you want to waste but there's something
to be said for H7 H6 just not to be
annoyed by this bishop G5 move
so you start with H6 yeah
I mean I'm a little bit worried about
something because again all I need is a
draw and I start looking at very forcing
lines such as this one
if I start thinking all I need is a draw
right I start to say uh
is this good or not
um
and he did play H6 by the way he did
and uh
I like your line actually
but it is very committal maybe you don't
need to do two Bishops right right just
go see three or well another way of
doing it if you
trying if you really are oh you can take
on F3 I apologia I apologize I was
thinking the bishop goes back to B7 uh
D5 and so on okay yeah I think it's not
necessary I think you can just sit there
with that extra space
there's your 55 is on the board okay he
takes D5 okay takes D5 and C4 yes
well again you know when you want that
drawn you can do it from a position of
strength like you know you can go C40
and but but am I it is Wesley right uh
I'm not sure
to keep the game yeah to keep the game
interesting and keep the game alive
yes he's playing Bishop B7
oh just Bishop F4
that's a different approach by Wesley
excuse me Bishop takes D5 Bishop takes
D5 but this is four I mean this should
be encouraging signs for uh for Levon
right is it just have two Bishops on the
board none of those Bishops are going to
get locked out of the game wait wait a
minute I mean Wesley's got a dark Square
strategy basically he wants to go 95 he
wants to trade Knights and Bishops on
the E5 square and he wants to Cozy up to
this guy Queen E3
that was a very very different approach
than when I was playing Bishop takes D5
I was doing it to play D5 Wesley has his
own ideas he just I'm not saying it's a
bad position for white I'm just saying
it's the type of position but Lavon was
dreaming of at the beginning of this
game I think that's fair get some
chances right well to get an imbalance
that may be favorable to Bishops
okay but you've got to come up with a
move after this Rook D1 and let's
suppose Queen's Queen okay wait actually
I don't want to give you my Pawn no no
no I don't want to allow you to take on
C7
you'll take it you'll take it yes I
would I you're you you got that Rook C8
you got that I mean after that last game
I don't think Lavon is going to LEAP
upon hanging for another two weeks
that's it these guys take those pawns
okay Queen E3 King H7
first
95. and everything with Tempo yeah yep I
I sort of like what you're doing
I I I I understand it it's it's what
about ideas like F5
[Music]
don't move backwards
he did not include the move Queen E3
which I thought was actually a nice
little touch he went 95 right away
said I don't need Queen E3 95 he wants
to take and he wants to play the move
Bishop to E5 and then you would play
your F6 you would then so you know
white will provoke that by the way
also useful little flick b2b3 just to
make sure that
whatever happens in the future I'm not
hanging my B3 my a4con
Christian how do you evaluate this
position look I like it for white you
like it for of course I like it for
white but once again I'm not changing my
stance I still think that Levon has his
chances nevertheless look white has more
space beautiful central control the
Bishops are nice and open but you don't
have any Targets on those diagonals
right yeah there's no targets there's no
way to get to my G2 pawn and if you
could be landing a queen on G5 to try to
attack my Pawn on G2 that would be nice
unfortunately you're never getting there
and any sort of traits
give me the advantage because all I need
is a draw right by the way at some point
I might even consider sacrificing upon
so for example you go even that position
G5 you have to do something yes I
understand indication that not all is
going that well he's a pro caution to
the win at this point yeah and someone
else who needs who needs to throw
caution to the wind
um if we could have energy it's Naji
against honestly and
Bishop H2 in fact played and here we see
well a very dynamic position I'm wow
this is a confusing position I want to
say okay C4 F5
wow okay
G5 Knight D2 Rook A5
um
we don't see positions like this every
day you almost feel like watch it again
I'm okay for but yeah right even though
you can't give away the beat the beat
but uh Alice playing Rook A3 which is
there so what if I continue okay
I guess we're game on ah you just want
to exchange everything like that yeah
well Alice is in the driver she she's
the one who won uh the first game that's
true normally speaking when you've got
your Pawn on F4 your ideas involve you
know going Whole Hog on the king side
there's not a lot of attacking pieces
and how are we doing on time
what is the situation so in the clock
times it is uh Alice around about five
and a half minutes and uh under five
minutes yeah
so how does the engine evaluate this I
I'm not sure let me take a look I like
it actually says black is slightly
better black is slightly better Rook
takes A3 by the way not with that move
I'm assuming Queen takes A3
black is still slightly slightly better
but she lost a lot of her Advantage with
that movie yeah I'm just wondering what
black so what is the next few moves that
blacker says is supposed to play she's
going to put a bishop on E5 you have to
focus on the weaknesses you have to
focus on the pawn on B5
so Rook to C8 followed by Queen to C5 is
going to allow me to get to the B5 Pawn
gotcha so I think that's the plan that
Naji needs to take
no no just Rook C8 you see it first and
yeah I want to go Queen C5 I want to
exchange the Queens so that whenever I
land on C5 I'm also attacking the the
pawn on B2 with my Bishop okay there's
no more defense on that pawn okay and by
the way
to win yes then we're gonna go on to
those let's playoffs so okay Queen takes
A3 and this is where Rook C8 and queen
C5 is prescribed by Christian may bring
by my engine by my Christian's engine
there you go I may bring uh success some
sort of success yes right yes it's still
very close to equality right now
okay
I'm talking about equality yeah I'm
gonna make you uh yeah back to the
bishop H2O G6 G5 uh kind of pushing me
to the bishop H2 Square by the way when
I see the move G6 G5 I'm like a bird of
prey I am immediately start thinking you
know like how can I bring a knight to
the H5 square like that is just you know
it's in my blood that uh I would want to
occupy that square let's see what
happened oh lots of moves happen wow
I'll say
Bishop
H2 F5 well Victor would be proud Victor
would be proud here we go takes takes
takes I won a pawn Wesley said I'll take
it
and he's played F3 in order to bring his
Bishop back to life
with uh the move Bishop to G1 this is an
extra Pawn guys uh b2b3 and Bishop to D1
and that's what Wesley's doing and
Wesley saying
you know I'm gonna win this match by
taking your Pawns yeah there is that but
there's also Rook d8 on and then you
know you just circle like the proverbial
vulture that you talked about yeah on
the weeknights C5 is coming are you just
gonna hold on to that one with all your
life yes uh uh no uh I was about to
I was I was really I'm almost blundered
it gave me everything this is what yes I
know Bishop usually the king is not on
F1 in these positions but Bishop takes
C4 would be a little bit awkward
so no Knight D5 you were about to
suggest 92 and just hold on with
everything no way through unless there
is Bishop um
five I think you just you're kind of
coming to the end uh to the end of the
road here you you did everything you
could but you didn't break through
Wesley was looking pretty confident at
the moment let me just uh do a repeat of
the current position as B3 is on the
board Wesley is just ready to play
Bishop to G1 consolidate his extra Pawn
on the on the queen side
and by the way Alice seems to be
breaking through as well
let's uh jump back
the last sequence of moves yeah C3
okay sorry we were just here Rook takes
A3 Queen takes a sacrificing a pawn
did Naji did Naji break through you mean
uh sorry yes yes yes nausea is breaking
through oh
you threw us off on that one
we had a long break
uh Rook E1 she didn't take on B5 uh
surprise for me she just played the move
Rook C8 was that a good move wrote the
C8 can I go uh Queen A7 that's my
question Bishop takes pawn and I think
Alice is about to ask nope
you didn't want the pawn on B5 I'll keep
it said Alice I don't blame her yeah I
don't blame her either and queen C5
check and I would move my king to F1
because you've got to stop the queen
getting to F2 and you're right she did
it
King to F1 now it you know I'm a little
bit worried that if I end up capturing
that might be some kind of draw and I've
got to play the in that situation which
I have to play for a win I'm going to
play Rook
A8 I should have done it and the
question here is yes does the Golden
Rule work it should Queen it should be
followed it doesn't matter if it works
or not it should be followed when did
the Golden Rule let's go for it
okay Alex I understand
she's listened to the broadcast
okay uh
well there's not much I can do about the
Golden Rule here is there I I suppose I
should play Rook A2 and
and play Rook and Bishop versus rook and
Knight
okay two
just hope that you the the night's quite
passive isn't it you know you just there
but
it's not
there you know it's not going G3 to F5
or something
well give it some time if you're
careless exactly uh Queen takes C5 would
would cut off that root but if you could
go Knight to D4 so Rook A2
two minutes to two minutes this is when
it starts to kind of feel that you're
down upon oh yeah sorry a point in the
match because normally with an equal
score you would be taking on B4 and then
go okay two things of that nature right
but do you want to trade the Queens when
you're uh no in this particular case I I
was thinking um I don't mind trading
Queens but I'd like to do it on my terms
and double my pawns B6 takes C5 yes so
that at least I'm stopping this gateway
to good squares good outposts for the
night which you did Rook to C1 to defend
that pawn you have to defend that pawn
and then Rook to beat or Rook B2 just
following your recommendation
by the way all right so what about C3
now you take on C4 I go Rook A1 that's
embarrassing but I will go back
no then you then you'll seize the open
file right I think she might have missed
this C3 move guys I I'm not unhappy I'll
play Rook A4 it's not like this Pawn is
running away immediately no way
yeah King E1
I just don't think you have enough
anymore
oh look what Rook A1 excuse me but
isn't that
okay one king D2 King D3 how how do you
defend that that Rook
okay he wanted to take on C3 yes yeah
but you can go Rook A3 Rook A3 is a
preload I love rookie three are you in
time to defend your roof you're going to
go E6 you're going to take on D5 and
then try to get the king to E5 in time
so let's let's go okay move by move Rook
to eight and if you go E6 how about now
you can go
three let's just see who gets there
first right King D5 on the board
King E5 and you get there just in time
boy talk about a close
call I can go in this case after the the
pawn on B7 Rook A7 but that's the
difference wait wait just a second wait
just a second
go there isn't this just Susan
what do you mean no no I go B6 I go B6
and just say okay you can't move your
king is trapped all I need is a draw
that is true that's true I put my Pawn
on H3 and now I move my Rook Rook A2
Rook a three okay two I'm not even
considering Rook A7 and try to play for
a win I hear you well I just sit like
this I and I think you're absolutely
right the problem is you cannot even
take on C3 because you lose the Rook as
well exactly at the end of it and we do
have E6 on the board oh he she 246 no
that's that's not a good idea but she
can do exactly the same The Rook is not
going anywhere you're right about that
that's a good point Joey yep two two
but wait a minute in this case you just
take the corn and King is continues is
not going anywhere your rookies it's
incredible that Rook is completely stuck
oh you can try to go G4 but I'm never
touching the pawn on G4 Alice is going
to the finals guys she is
and it looks like yep it looks like
Wesley and Lavon are also drawing their
game I mean
oh yes very simple this is a draw we
don't even have to yeah no we don't have
to go there so that's it
then it will be Wesley moving to the
Grand Final and live on Iranian sadly it
leaves the competition
we have clock times not significant it's
the position The Rook on C4 there's
nothing it's trapped it's such a sad
position
I mean maybe she can try to go G4 but I
mean you can just stand you you just sit
you put the pawn on H3 on the light
squares and you just wait 20 seconds for
Naji
hp5 that's fine King D3 no problem
the only thing you can hope right now is
that Alice decides that she wants to
play for a win and goes through K7 Rook
B7
yeah
she is not going to do that at all
you've got to actually recognize this H5
H3 but in fact she can even go Rook A8
try to win The Rook
oh maybe that's a good idea
I mean that's so easy and she recognized
Rook A8 and uh now you just wait
uh Rook G8 releasing no no no let's not
break this beautiful position I can move
my knight now exactly I can go Knight C1
Knight B3 Knight D2 how do you stop me
from that H3 good move h3h4 that's fine
Knight C1 how do you stop me from there
you can't Knight C1 Knight B3 Knight E2
like you say ah you go Bishop E7 and
then Bishop F6 and now you control both
d8 and C3 uh-huh
gotcha okay just go Rook A7 okay
B6 B6 I like this move yeah you know by
the way we do have a draw
and uh Wesley moves on to the Grand
Final against Chicago
so uh
that will be a great rematch to watch
Bishop
to E7 on the board
I think she wants to go
yeah I think you're right I think she's
tempted by King C2 and King B3 she is
yeah uh no Rook A3 good for her she
understands nothing to do d8 Bishop to
d8 now Rook to A8
same ideas as before Oh look A7 this ma
no no it takes B6 I take on B7 and Rook
D7 so you're in trouble now yep yep yep
yep yep yep I am but Bishop to A5 with
Rook A4 in mind
Rook D7
and I take the rook and I take the pawn
on C5 true I I cannot lose that like
sure you're probably maybe you're going
to be able to make it you're right
Rook check is uh I don't have any pawns
on dark swears he said Pawn on C3 which
is
no Rook check is good enough
because that that can get complicated
don't allow that go Rook D7 she is
thinking yes I think she was thinking
about Rook G7 and Rook takes G5 she said
why why keep why complicate King C6 King
takes C4
that's that's the money move right now
Alice has seen it and she's done it and
this is the easy win
yeah easy win no weaknesses absolutely
no way to lose this position no get the
king to E4 Knight to D4 invade with the
King via F5 this is it guys wow we have
our second Grand finalist of the day
absolutely and it all it took was a
double
uh player to get to separate them
incredible stuff nice Knight D4 check
King to D5 oops it's gonna March up the
board
use that person helpless
and uh
Nazi probably knows it right now
it's hopeless yes right now the position
is hopeless
five five whoa King to D5 she's trying
to promote that pawn
not convinced why also she has no E6 she
certainly does I mean it's just a joy
for Alice to play exactly she's got this
it's one of those impossible to lose
positions right right it's just like
really impossible to lose especially to
make some really bad in G2 I mean even
if black plays a move like G4 and you
don't capture it you know it's like the
pawn on G2
is there three two okay now seven
and often it takes Bishop I'm expecting
Naji just uh call it a day nope
never won a game by resigning nobody
ever has well apparently I was corrected
on that statement really yeah
somebody won a game anybody won a game
by resigning because it turned out that
the person who resigned
obviously resigned try to resign and
there you go
and the other opponent felt bad because
he in fact had cheated early on oh
wow a Karma and congratulations to Alice
Lee as she sets up
deja vu all over again I mean we were
here last year and uh the same thing
Arena had to win two matches to uh win
the American Cup and she'll have her the
same opponent to do it against as well
two matches
matches and who who were the predictions
what were the predictions like shall we
just review our predictions
I don't think you've got a participation
trophy okay I said Wesley
well we say goodbye
this anomalies in the ladies I know
foreign
yeah but okay nice but uh
congratulations on your participation
thank you thank you we'll make sure to
get you a certificate and here's where
we stand
um we're at Grand finals take a look at
this tomorrow tomorrow we will be seeing
a huge rematch as it is Alice Lee which
has defeated
and she will be marching to the Grand
Final where she will meet none other
than Arena Crush
and here you can see their lifetime
match up two wins for arena no losses
five draws and what will what will be
the uh the tempo for these two uh Grand
Final matches today we'll be reverting
to classical
so for Alice you know it's been a very
quick change of pace but then she's back
to the Rhythm and here we can see the
huge championship match between Hikaru
and Nakamura and Wesley so who's just
defeated Lavon aronian and uh take a
look at that lifetime matchup In
classical well Wesley will be safe yeah
Wesley will be saying well let's play
those classical games but Westie does
have a much tougher job ahead of him
because obviously you know he's lost a
Hikaru so this means he needs to defeat
Hikaru not once but twice twice and
guess who is in studio with Christian
you just pointed at the screen Wesley
and you were surprised by that the
lifetime matchup score as well yeah why
why is it so uh
well because a very strong player and I
think the wins I had him against
I had against him in the classical was
like seven years ago so it was such a
long time ago I think
but I don't even remember beating him
four times I think I remember the thing
filled cup and then London chess classic
and then uh
where else did I beat him I don't even
think felt Cup London chess classic
2016-17 I don't even remember the
probably a long time ago it must have
been a long time we don't know for sure
I don't even remember but one thing
Wesley I wanted to ask you sum up the
last couple of days for you because
yes
such difficult days right such difficult
matchups both the one with Hikaru but
today's matchup was very very difficult
as well and nothing to separate you with
the white pieces you were getting
something in both matches but totally
winning totally winning exactly but then
towards the end when you had only
seconds on the clock it felt like nerves
were taking over did you feel that way
as well yeah basically anymore worth
winning but
I mean I don't really mind that much
what happens I mean I didn't find the
Lebanese a great and wonderful player
also so it's Fabi but uh I mean I don't
find the matches real difficult I'm just
very happy to still be in the tournament
that's all that matters I still got one
life left and uh get my main focus this
year and last year was classical chef
although it doesn't seem I'm getting
nowhere with it but uh what happens in
Blitz and rap it doesn't really matter
that much to me and just from class
because I win good if not that's fine
too but today was obviously a wonderful
day and I'd like to glorify the Lord in
Jesus for and that's a very interesting
thing to say about mental fortitude and
in those difficult moments you know you
were winning with the white pieces you
lose that one right against
you come back but then you take it to
the Blitz and then unfortunately losing
that one what did you tell yourself at
night to get back into this competition
and make sure you win today's match well
it wasn't easy I think for any player
it's not easy to
lose a winning game but I just my mom
helped me but my I just tell myself that
this is part of the game that's what
chess is about uh
Sometimes the best player wins sometimes
it doesn't happen and you know mistakes
are
part of the game then my secret is just
to keep improving keep improving you
know there'll always be missed chances
always going to be blunders made but
uh
he just tried to keep improving to
increase your rating
and if the chips fall her way and it's
good if nothing just keep working keep
working keep playing these tournaments
keep trying right yeah that's why
they're not here I'm like the only
player who doesn't have a rest day in
the room and I also think this is my
fifth tournament in a row I've been
playing non-stop for eight weeks played
in why I can't say like it played in
Dusseldorf
also played some online so uh but uh
you know I love Jess I'm very grateful
to the thing feels the thing with chess
club for hosting tournaments like this
giving people like me and linear work
and uh
you know if it
if it goes your way then that's good if
if not just try to keep getting now
that's a very interesting thing you
mentioned you've been playing for a lot
of weeks and we were discussing this in
the studio as well what do you do to
keep your physical shape ready for this
type of stretch stretches yeah fun thing
that could be improved upon
like I was reading about Bobby Fisher in
the museum and that's one thing he's
really really good at he's so he's so
physically strong and so is Magnus
Carlsen so that's definitely one thing I
could
improve upon but try to
guess I try to exercise the Ender take
long walks during a tournament
I try to swim when I'm back home swim
two or three times a week for an hour
uh I try to also eat healthy when I was
younger I could eat anything I wanted
I'm getting close to 30. the doctor told
me I have to watch my diet here and
there
and uh
try to you know eat healthier try to eat
more fruits and vegetables try to sleep
12 hours every night 12 hours okay okay
yeah I mean it's not easy but I try to
learn better on 13 hours a night
because during the game
um you need your full concentration when
when I'm back at home I don't really
need much sleep but when I'm in a
tournament try to get as much as
possible also so on Bobby Fisher's
interview he he wakes up like an hour
half an hour before the game so he comes
to the game very fresh for me it's a bit
different like I do some review here and
there but I usually wake up around three
two and a half hours before a game
that's very interesting and very
revealing thank you for telling us all
these secrets
left the fame he just wakes up and then
goes to play a game and maybe that's a
secret but I try to learn from great
players guys join the conversation well
uh first of all just simply our
congratulations you're in the finals and
uh you're very very deserving I know
what you mean about that free day Wesley
it could have gone your way uh yes uh
yesterday but you you you came back in
the elimination and so just a hat tip
well done and just keep going you're
Jovi yeah no I just also wanted to say
congratulations and
I wanted to ask you about your
preparations for today actually because
obviously you've been playing classical
games and then you had to switch to the
rapid against Lavon how did you adjust
uh well I just you know
again just try to sleep well don't
try not to stress myself too much just
try to be very relaxed very calm I took
a look at some of lebon's recent
openings prepared some small ideas here
and there
but nothing really stressful maybe for I
just prepared just for half an hour and
then uh
just left yes listen to music as they
usually do okay question we'll be trying
to get the relaxed or in good shape and
I think I played pretty pretty decently
today like I looked I look at some of my
games with the computer I think I played
pretty okay so that's uh that's a very
good sign but after this tournament I'll
have a five week break so I look forward
to watching the world championship match
with Ian ending and spending some rest
before going to Christian's Hometown
Romania yes yes yeah yeah I'll see you
there for sure that should be an
interesting one we'll have to get our
ticket and try to arrive a few days
early
Wesley thank you very much for joining
the show congratulations we'll see you
tomorrow thanks and again our
congratulations Wesley indeed as I this
is what tomorrow is going to look like
yeah and we have a championship match
and both in the open and women's section
we're gonna see one classical game
that was that will be the Prelude to all
the action that will be having happening
the following day when the players will
conclude the match come what may exactly
and how do they alternate the colors for
that they uh I think that's always the
highest highest rated player in the
classical highest seed and uh this one
uh two wins as we've seen uh for arena
no losses by draws as Alice Lee fights
her way into the uh finals and she is
with Christian
at least I see you smiling from year to
year you're definitely very happy this
was a tough match you were putting a lot
of pressure with the white pieces but
she was returning the favor as well
putting a lot of pressure early on with
the white pieces sum it up for us this
match
um yeah so the first game I thought it
went pretty well I wasn't expecting her
opening but
um I think I was able to handle it not
the best but it was enough
um and then later I had this nice Queen
taxi 5 tactic
um the second game
um she played this opening line with G4
which is very aggressive but um playing
for a win and I think it was definitely
a good
um opening for that but and I wasn't
prepared so uh I think she was able to
uh win very nicely in that game
um for the rap again I'm actually really
glad that I got black first because
um it's after I won that game of course
it wasn't easy but it felt like we were
both we don't specifically play for a
winner specifically play for a draw and
I thought it was easier to be black
first and then after I was able to win
this game it was a bit different but
that was not an easy game she was really
pressuring you but you did make some
switches early on in the opening Digi
discuss with your coach in between the
games did you come prepared with a
different weapon yeah so I thought that
she might try the G4 weapon again
because uh of course it's like I don't
need to play for a win and it worked out
well for her
um so I I prepared in between around
this
um B6 line and it sort of transposes
into a semi-slaw with like Bishop E2
Queen T2 castles and
um I think that's also a line it was a
bit different for me because I played
Rook C8 because I didn't want to cast on
Toshi Castle so I'm not sure what how
much that changed the opening but I sort
of knew the plans but I did feel like my
position was worse at some point it was
yes but you did find this very nice idea
and I have to point it out to you I
really like this move Knight to B4 oh
yeah just looking like you're giving
away the Knight but you're actually just
hunting the queen down yeah I thought
that I I really liked that move because
um uh it's not easy for her she had a
load Time To Save the Queen she played
Bishop A4 which was the best movie eight
um did you see this move Rook to A8 from
the get-go when he played night before
no I missed Bishop A4
um but yeah here
um I guess yeah she can play Bishops C3
and then it's hard but it's already
quite difficult for her as well and it's
very tempting to sacrifice the queen and
it looks like you have this very
dangerous b or a pawn and it seems like
you have enough compensation yeah I was
pretty happy because I thought of these
Queen five five ideas and it's not easy
for
easy for India after this I think I was
able to win this is already I was happy
that I got white in the uh the next
games instead of having to like play for
the defense yeah yeah
um and this game was the first game was
off also like pretty chaotic so uh and
the second came I feel like I probably
played a little bit too passively in the
opening but
um after we turned into the end game I
was pretty happy with the idea I found
um I was up a pond so then I played C30
um once you caught The Rook on C4 it
felt like it was pretty much game over
and you smoothly went on to convert your
advantage tomorrow you will be facing uh
Irina Crush once again you faced her in
the finals you faced her in the finals
of the Champions bracket as well was
going to uh happen tomorrow how are you
going to take her down
um I'm not sure
obviously I think last match it was okay
for the classical portion
um but she did beat me in the rapid
playoffs uh so I'll probably have to
make some adjustments in my general
strategy but for now I'm not sure I was
mostly just focusing on on this match
and it's good that I was able to win
this one guys our congratulations Alice
go get some rest and good luck tomorrow
thank you absolutely wow another great
game and another great day of American
Cup knockout I know I love this system
me too I mean it's it's it's it's so
nice to call it it really is and there's
just so much action so much content and
truly you know these matches could have
gone either way in the end we've got the
match-ups we could have expected them
Christian final thoughts as we wrap up
today and I want to build that on that
on what you said yeah sir this matches
between these four players have been so
competitive we remember that match uh
between Wesley so and Hikaru Nakamura
that are finalized in the blitz section
right and it could have went either way
because Wesley was definitely putting
the pressure in that match as well and
well Irina was half a second away from
being sent to the elimination bracket so
anything can happen tomorrow we do have
the grand finals we could also have a
winner after the next couple of days so
stay tuned we will be here to provide
all the action and do commentary for you
guys
well with that thank you everybody for
joining us and we will see you all
tomorrow
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited